Guten morgen tim.
Aux
Logbuch netz politik nummer dreihundert und sieben vom zehnten.
Juli zweitausendneunzehn wir haben ein bisschen pause machen müssen weil es sommer und auch andere dinge zu tun du wirst auch gleich berichten was ich in den letzten wochen vor allem davon abgehalten hat.
Sollen wir sollen wir noch den status quo drei null sieben kurz hier referieren.
Oh da war glaube ich einige gelegenheiten schon ausgelassene letzten sonntag.
Ja heute drei null sieben ist seltener ne man muss drei null sieben eigentlich nicht so häufig aber es war auch ein tempo.
Einer meiner lieblingslieder lieblingsstadt.
Ja drei null drei null eins muss permanent liegen benutzt man gerne mal drei null zwei ja aber.
Ja drei null zwei found ist so der der sich noch sehr viel im internet befindet da wo man eigentlich drei null sieben meint.
Genau man müsste eigentlich drei null sieben machen ne also ein gut gemeinter und häufig unterschätzt da status der durchaus eigentlich öfter mal zur anwendung kommen könnte.
Ja meine aufs gefühl bei der kandidaten suche auf eu-ebene sind.
Na die wollte es ja nicht wirklich mit hatte viel status kurz machen aber es geht in die richtung ja.
Ein bisschen ein bisschen ja jetzt soll es also ursel richten das ist natürlich sehr interessant.
Und wie sagte ich so schön zensur solar ich weiß gar nicht wer jetzt von euch hörerinnen und hörern diesen begriff kennt ich vermute mal 'ne menge aber bestimmt nicht alle.
Ist das jetzt hier.
Zweitausendneun zehn jahre.
Tausend neunzehn jahre ist es ja echt oh man krass das ist eigentlich ganz interessant da kann man wirklich nochmal daran erinnern weil dann muss ich auch sagen das war für mich so ein bisschen
der moment wo ich das gefühl hatte dass diese ganze netz politische,
gegenbewegung ein wie sagt man so schön ein momentum entwickelt hat was ich so vorher noch nicht gesehen habe.
Klar ich mein der club und kritik ort und viele andere gruppen haben wir schon immer so ihre themen besetzt aber man hatte nie so das gefühl nennenswert gehör zu finden geschweige denn
irgendeine nennenswerte unterstützung so zu bekommen in der bevölkerung.
Und als dann unsere damalige hat man kraft welches.
Familienministerin oder.
Nachher richtig familien das familienministerium das wurde auch mit ursula.
Von der leyen besetzt und dann gab's halt wieder diese uhr kinderpornografie böse inhalte im internet wir müssen unsere kinder schützen debatte die ja wie alle paar jahre hochkommt wenn mal wieder irgendwas verschärft werden muss,
und da hatte sie diese gloria jose idee dennis basierte webseiten blocker einzuführen.
Technisch alles etwas löcher ruhig und kurz gedacht und so oder so weil sich aber hier um ein zensur system handelte aus unserer perspektive.
Natürlich vor allem wieder mal so ein.
Eine technische einrichtung auf staats ebene die in irgendeiner form missbraucht werden kann dementsprechend hat sich da widerstand,
gebildet und da kam es dann so ein paar interessante demonstrationen war ich irgendwie auch selber dabei und war vor allem sehr überrascht wie viel leute auf einmal da waren ich für junge leute dabei waren die namen.
Das war
also wir hatten zu dem zeitpunkt schon den zensur den arbeitskreis vorrat den arbeitsplatz vorzeigen speicherung der sich ja immer in den kampf gegen die vorratsdatenspeicherung engagiert hat und die,
diese idee
stop schilder auf stopp schilder halt zu verteilen das war so dieses bei der vorstellung hielt sie dann auch so ein stoppschild hoch war dann so in
in der was ist das ein ein stoppschild stand in der mitte stopp drauf mit doppelt t p und ausrufezeichen
ihr internet browser versucht grade kontakt zu einer webseite herzustellen die im zusammenhang mit der verbreitung von kinderpornografie genutzt wird kinderpornografie
kaffee stellt sexuelle mit missbrauch handlung an kindern da die verbreitung der werbung der besitz von kinderpornografie ist nach paragraph hundertvierzig b strafgesetzbuch strafbar,
vier weitere absätze interessant an der auseinandersetzung fand ich vor allem.
Auch das wieder so eine war wo du eigentlich denkst die kannst du nicht gewinnen wir hatten auseinandersetzung über irgendwelche formen von next sperren am laufenden band im bereich des sharing,
und,
solange du über solche themen redest redest du noch über irgendwie halbwegs sinnvolle vielleicht oder nachvollziehbare ausgleiche von grundrechten und interessen aber wenn es um mit diesem thema kinderpornografie oder terror,
erinnert euch
terror filter eben auch ein thema was wir auf eu-ebene besprechen da hast du auf jeden fall erstmal schlechtere karten umso überraschender eigentlich dass hier die stimmung so,
so krass gewandelt ist denn das ist eine netz politische erfolgsgeschichte der kampf gegen das zugangs erschweren ausgesetzt.
Genau so ist der.
Vorstoß von ursula von der leyen hat sie sich nicht so richtig mit durchsetzen können,
und von daher
war dann glaube ich keiner so richtig traurig als sie in ihre neue rolle als verteidigungsministerium um getopft wurde später.
Aber ganz kurz ich muss noch wir müssen noch erwähnen warum warum sie das ding verloren hat denn der leitspruch der gegenbewegung war löschen statt sperren.
Ja es gab damals übrigens wer da auch noch dann der ursula von der leyen sehr zur seite gesprungen ist war der karl theodor gutenberg.
Der dann nämlich auch sagte so erfinde das ja.
Skandalös dass hier diese netz politischen bewegungen.
Irgendwie sich für die verbreitung von kinderpornografie einsetzen und hat dann da auch so die freie zugang zu wissen und so weiter diese ganzen,
die fraktionen da mit kredit mit diskreditieren wollen und der entscheidende ich denke das entscheidende gegenargument was dann auch wirklich in der breite der
gesellschaft auch nachvollziehbar.
Zugänglich unverständlich war war der punkt löschen statt sperren was die nämlich technisch vorgeschlagen haben war 'ne 'ne sperre oft ebene.
Ihr wisst ja der dkms ist das.
Der das protokoll der server der euch die schönen domain haben dir ein tipp facebook dot com übersetzt in die ip-adresse der server zu denen ihr verbindet also letztendlich ein.
Sehr sehr zentraler dienst für das internet weil wir in wenigen fällen noch wirklich mit ip-adresse
radikalen minderheit der verbindungen die wir herstellen arbeiten wir wirklich über die ip-adresse ohne vorher mal noch gefragt zu haben.
Und der sollte einfach in den fällen andere antworten geben nämlich umleiten zum bka.
Oder zu irgendwie staatlich betriebenen servern wo dann eben ein stoppschild präsentiert wird und die die kern problematik ist damit wird es zwar für die kunden die diesen.
Oder der zugang erschwert nicht aber für alle.
Weltweit die andere deren server nutzen oder die.
Die sag ich mal gezielt auf dieses server zugreifen wollen mit anderen worten dass die kriminalität wird versteckt.
Und nicht bekämpft,
und das denke ich war das das entscheidende argument was dann auch wirklich gab es ein verein den gibt 's sicherlich immer noch mit missbrauchsopfern gegen internet sperren.
Also selbst betroffene person den für deren leben dieses thema eine.
Große rolle spielt haben sich quasi gegen diese gegen diesen decken mantel des schweigens gegen diese sperren ausgesprochen und für eine aktive strafverfolgung illegaler.
Illegaler tätigkeiten hinzu kam natürlich noch viele technische probleme die zum beispiel damit einhergehenden das erste was du jetzt,
machen würdest mit deiner,
mit den illegalen inhalten ist die halt irgendwo hinlegen wo noch andere sachen liegen mit anderen worten wird es sehr viele große kollateralschaden bei sperrungen und natürlich ging das auch ein bisschen an der realität vorbei dass solche.
Aktivitäten jetzt wirklich im offenen und freien internet stattfinden würden wo du irgendwie auf w w w kinder sex de gehen würdest und.
Was weiß ich dann da irgendwie sich einloggt und dir was angucken kannst gab auch irgendwie eine sehr schöne,
theorie da gibt es ein ein historisches interview mit ursula von der leyen das hatte den titel da werden kinder seelen zerfetzt und war glaube ich in irgendeiner morgenpost.
Wo sie so ein bisschen eigentlich visionär so diese rapid hol.
Abendblatt soll nicht morgen posten dann abendblatt hamburger abendblatt hat sie da ein interview geführt wo sie das sogar zweitausendacht november zweitausendachtzehn stories also nicht zehn jahre her sondern elf.
Wo sie,
und dann sagte ja man man das fängt ja mit mit das fängt schon mit software an und dann wird man durch werbung auf auf immer jüngere kinder gezogen und das muss irgendwie verhindert werden also es wird
eine geschichte also in der form von von wenigen menschen erfahren wurde.
Naja letztendlich äh ursprünglich wollte sie das über freiwillige sperren machen dann über eine änderung des telemedizin gesetzes breiter protest dagegen trotz sag ich mal der schwierigen ausgangssituation,
hier sehr einfach eben auch,
in der diskreditierung rennen zu können und der versuche das auch aktiv zu betreiben von ursula von der leyen von karl theodor von uns zu und hinter und oben und drüber gutenberg die.
Dann letztendlich dieses gesetz wurde ich glaube dann noch erlassen.
Aber von horst köhler dem damaligen bundespräsident irgendwie direkt außer kraft gesetzt.
Beziehungsweise nicht unterschrieben.
Hat er es nicht unterschrieben.
Nicht mehr ganz genau also meine erinnerung ist jetzt ohnehin schon so schwach bin schon ganz beeindruckt was du alles nass noch nach zehn jahren hier so außer.
Tim das ist ein fluch.
Ja ich weiß ich bin ganz froh dass ich den nicht habe aber beeindruckt mich da trotzdem immer.
Der.
Damals es gab eine petition dagegen die glaube ich zu dem zeitpunkt auch die erfolgreichste petition war die irgendwie unter bundestag der immer stattgefunden hat und wenn.
Ich mich nicht täusche und jeder der also ich glaube das wurde irgendwie nicht da muss ich jetzt nochmal ganz kurz gucken.
Es wurde verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben und irgendwie hatte der köhler das.
Erstmal nicht genau es wurde ein beschluss zu nicht umsetzung genau den gab es dann und hin und her auf jeden fall am ende haben wir da gewonnen.
Und das hat denke ich dir dieser netz politischen bewegung das war einer der schlüssel momente auch zu zeigen
freier zugang zu den reichen und mächtigen nicht unangenehm nicht angenehmen inhalten noch eine sehr viel größere rolle spielen sollte in der zukunft werden wir dann so an,
zehn ist die wikileaks und sonstiges denken also da hat ursula von der leyen wirklich,
der netz politischen bewegung letztendlich einen sehr großen gefallen.
Ja sie war auch so ein bisschen dann auch das symbol der dieser politiker generation die halt versucht dinge zu regeln mit der sie kulturell einfach keinerlei nennenswerte verbindung hatte.
Betrifft natürlich auch viele andere aber
bei ihr kam es dann eben ganz deutlich hervor und erdgas hat ja dann diesen schönen spitznamen zensur solar in einem tweet ausgepackt der dann schnell um sich griff und
der klebt.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen in vergessenheit geraten aber mal gucken was sie jetzt noch irgendwie bringt jetzt kommt ja schon mit anderen korken irgendwie im rahmen ihrer bewerbung und ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt ob das parlament hier die traute hat ihr vielleicht noch ein stoppschild vorzuhalten.
Oh je das war äh also ich habe das nur so ein bisschen verfolgt diese auseinandersetzung da um den timmermans und den weber ähm.
Aber da jetzt auf aus dem hut.
Diese ursula von der leyen zu zaubern ist wirklich also ich habe da viele viele kommentare zu gelesen wo die einen sagen nein das ist.
Das ist nicht undemokratisch sondern es ist so ist halt der prozess und das geht weil es so vorgesehen ist während andere sagen.
Es mag vielleicht jetzt irgendwie in ordnung ordnung sein aber es ist trotzdem nicht vermittelbar wenn menschen sich halt an der wahl beteiligen und da stehen diese spitzenkandidaten und plötzlich wird dann da irgendjemand aus dem hut gezaubert.
Die eigentlich zu hause noch ein untersuchungsausschuss auf sich warten hat und jetzt irgendwie kommissionspräsidenten werden soll ähm.
Ist auf jeden fall keine sternstunde der eu die da jetzt gerade stattfindet.
Du bist keine keine sternstunde in der vermittlung der ganzen geschichte weil ich.
Spitzenkandidaten nummer hat ja nun eigentlich auch nicht jeden überzeugt ne also das ganze wahlrecht allein schon
das ja so recht nicht her dass das kandidaten überhaupt in einer besonderen position sind das ist insbesondere in deutschland so wo du halt eine
bundesweite liste und nur das hast ja es gibt ja überhaupt gar keine möglichkeit auf einzelne kandidaten in irgendeiner form stimmen zu vereinigen ja also zumindest in form von wie ist das in manchen kommunalen gesetzgebung ja gibt im wahlrecht das formulieren passagieren das so quasi 'ne möglichkeit hast
'ne bestimmte stimme gewichtung noch einzelnen kandidaten geben zu geben zu können sodass die listen gewichtung sich noch ändert dass also unter umständen bestimmte kandidaten die tiefer der liste sind nach oben getragen werden
all das gibt es ja nicht her mal davon abgesehen dass wir ohnehin in jedem eu-land nochmal 'ne andere wahl rechtsordnung haben und das.
Großbritannien ganz anders läuft alles bei uns zum beispiel also ich
ich hab diese spitzenkandidaten nummer fand ich eben ein bisschen merkwürdig und dann war es ja aber auch nochmal besonders peinlich weil sie ja dann als sie es als es in die verhandlungen ging mit dem wahlergebnis was ja etwas kryptisch war ne also wo keine klaren mehrheiten bei rauskam
die övp war er noch die stärkste fraktion aber hat halt stark verloren grünen stärker geworden et cetera das haben wir ja alle schon mal erwähnt
und von daher gab's eben nicht so dieses klare die sozialdemokraten und die konservativen handeln jetzt mal aus wer von den beiden irgendwie da ist das selber ja überall das immer in britannien sind wir bei uns na das also dieser
traditionelle links rechts block in vertretung von konservativen und sozialdemokraten einfach wegbricht und jetzt durch andere kräfte von unten ergänzt wird,
und ja es war halt ein kompromiss möglich und vorher haben sie halt immer getönt ja das spitzenkandidaten modell das ist ja so wichtig das muss man ja unbedingt beibehalten und wenn man es daran nicht halten und bekomme denn da hin
sich mal kurz ins zimmer dann so ach ja übrigens wir nehmen jetzt mal irgendjemanden der noch nicht mal auf einer liste stand als ich meine.
Man könnte ja noch argumentieren für von der leyen
wenn sie tatsächlich sich zur europawahl hätte aufstellen lassen also irgendwie platz zwei oder sowas gewesen wäre aber nein
die hat ja überhaupt nicht vor nach europa zu geben und das ausgerechnet sie jetzt besser qualifiziert sein sollen als zum beispiel leute wieder franz timmermans ja der ja schon.
Verdienste hat der irgendwie klarer kopf ist der diese ganzen rechts verletzungs prozesse gegen ungarn polen und so weiter angestoßen hatten ja eigentlich nur deshalb jetzt nicht
gewählt wird,
weil eben ungarn und polen dagegen sind die wiese grad starten ist halt nochmal so ein skandal an sich also wir hätten ja da sozusagen wirklich ein legitimer anführer gehabt
der auch spitzenkandidat war und der auch in seinem eigenen land
extrem dazu gewonnen hat also sehr viel sprach für ihn und nur der widerstand der jenigen regierung die nun wirklich dem europa gedanken derzeit am weitesten entgegenstehen wenn man von der brexit party
absehen die arme sozusagen dazu geführt dass jetzt jemand auf einmal gewählt werden soll
der eben noch nicht mal zur wahl stand also ist schon wirklich alles ein bisschen absurd und jetzt richten sicher die blicke auf das parlament denn es ist nun mal so der rat der europäischen union also quasi die
gesamt menge aller regierung darf halt diesen vorschlag machen.
Und es ist aber so dass das parlament diesen vorschlag aber noch bestätigen muss und wenn halt ursula von allein in der im parlament.
Keine mehrheit bekommt dann war's das ne also das wird nochmal sportlich.
Ich arbeite im du du darfst nicht unbedingt an der qualifikation von ursula von der leyen pfeifen die hat vielleicht keine ahnung aber die hat halt gute beratung.
Das hier auch einiges kosten nun ja.
Wir wir müssen ein bisschen fäden zusammenziehen und ein paar an wir werden in dieser sendung ein paar angefangen die themen,
zu ende führen weil das hier ist das jetzt gehört habe war der prolog deswegen kommt jetzt kurz die themen übersichtlich mir versuche anzugewöhnen.
Wir reden nochmal ein bisschen über die fusion wir reden dann über der die.
Die währung wir reden über libra das facebook geld.
Und dann kurz über die fünf g auktion und den netzausbau dann reden wir ein bisschen über und dann müssen wir noch ein paar,
kurz meldungen machen thema gucken wie viele stunden wir dafür heute brauchen da geht's um
mail vw anbieter den darknet paragraphen noch ein bisschen ums zensur hebel recht und um den,
adblocker streit dann kommen wir mit den termin und dann ist die dreiviertel stunde auch schon.
Wenn du dich jetzt schon vorbei ist na gut.
Aufgrund aufgrund der der der gesamt gesellschaftlichen bedeutung einerseits aber auch aufgrund meiner persönlichen involviert übung in die angelegenheit haben wir hier ja über die fusion gesprochen,
die fusion hat jetzt stattgefunden und die geschichte,
gehört noch zu ende erzählt und ähm wie schrieb markus reuter bei netz politik org das fusion festival hat gezeigt dass freiheitsrechte verteidigt werden können und benennt das,
ein bisschen,
sagte ausgerechnet ein kulturfestival in mecklenburg-vorpommern gelingt es die bislang größtes schlacht des jahres gegenüber wachablösung zu gewinnen und das ist doch ein schönes,
fazit da reden wir dann jetzt mal drüber.
Genau also zum hintergrund vielleicht noch wer den schluss noch nicht gehört hat fusion festival eins der größten open air festivals in deutschland aber anders als viele andere festivals.
Un kommerziell aus einer community heraus über jahrzehnte jetzt entwickelt und getragen und von daher
auch ein ein ort des anders sein das ganze mit
ten als links politisch orientierte bewegung mitten in mecklenburg-vorpommern quasi wie so ein ganzes dorf umringt von,
nazi römern und das war noch nie so einfach und dann kam halt die polizei und wollte maßnahmen durchsetzen insbesondere das gelände patrioten und dagegen hatte sich der
widerstand gestemmt und kurz
vorher wurde das aber dann alles ab geblasen man hat sich anderweitig geeinigt es gab also diese patronen jetzt nicht stattdessen gab 's hoffentlich glückliche teilnehmer ich war leider nicht da aber du warst ja vor ort
an der front.
Ja es gab also der der kompromiss der vereinbart wurde also
das nochmal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen es gab die forderung nach einer mobilen wache auf dem
gelände auf dem festival-gelände von dieser mobilen wache aus sollten polizistinnen und polizisten streife gehen auf dem festivalgelände
und im weiteren verlauf durch eine veröffentlichung des investigative teams von zeit online stellte sich dann auch noch heraus dass in diesem einsatz konzept irgendwie eintausendeinhundert kräfte räumen panzer und wasserwerfer vorgesehen waren.
Es gab weiterhin von der polizei dann zweifel am sicherheitskonzept des des kultur- cosmos als veranstalter über dass es viele diskussionen gab der kompromiss der am ende erreicht wurde war,
tatsächlich der den der kultur kostenlos auch schon seit november zwanzig achtzehn vorgeschlagen hatte nämlich ihr könnt eure mobile wache am rande des geländes errichten also
außerhalb des festivalgelände so können die besucherinnen zu euch kommen wenn sie probleme haben.
Und natürlich kommt ihr wie auch schon in den vorjahren anlass bezogen auf das gelände allerdings nicht anlass los also anders bezogen heißt.
Es ist etwas wir möchten zu folgendem punkt ermitteln dann kann man da rein und danach geht man wieder weg und bleibt nicht einfach nur ein bisschen,
außerdem gab es tägliche treffen
zwischen den behörden also zwischen den relevanten behörden das ist dann so ordnungsamt und den relevanten stellen des veranstalters also sicherheitskräfte des veranstalters medizinische kräfte des veranstalters ordnungsamt.
Polizei die haben sich also einmal am tag getroffen zu einer lage besprechung und.
Interessanterweise ist das alles sehr,
freundlich und kooperativ gelaufen wir sind insbesondere von diesem der täglichen treffen und auch ja von der zusammenarbeit mit der.
Polizei sehr positiv überrascht das hat auch damit zu tun dass dem kultur kosmos ein.
Neuer ansprechpartner gegeben wurde von seiten der polizei also nachdem dann dieser konflikt einmal so hoch gekocht war und das dann eben auch jetzt.
Vorbei war und runter gekocht wurde einfach auch mal um den alten konflikt daraus zu schaffen von seiten der polizei ein neuer ansprechpartner gestellt.
Der wirklich einfach mal,
sehr darauf bedacht war zusammenzuarbeiten die gegenseitigen interessen zu waren auch sich gegenseitig ins vertrauen zu ziehen das war wirklich freundlich und kooperativ und für,
sag ich mal alle beteiligten zu beginnen.
Erstmal noch ein bisschen überraschend und misstrauen erregend und dann merkte man später das sind so hey hier der ist doch echt ganz in ordnung oder so ja ja ich bin auch ganz begeistert also das ist das ist das war einfach
gut ja der hat also die abrüstung nicht nur in form der kräfte stattgefunden,
sondern eben auch ein erkennbaren schwenk in der form der zusammenarbeit zurück,
zu vertrauensvolle freundlicher und kooperativer zusammenarbeit stattgefunden das muss man einfach mal so anerkennen dann wurde die,
mobile wache irgendwie ich glaub am boah ich weiß nicht welchen tag das war
ich glaube ein zwei tage vor dem vor festival beginnt wurde die geliefert wie kam war so ein zwei container die da anfangen mit dem tieflader
und wir sind natürlich neugierig als erstes dorthin gegangen er war ja klar dass diese wache jetzt irgendwie noch eine rolle spielen würde während des festivals haben sie angeschaut das waren also zwei container dazwischen sonstige gespannt.
Und das erste was uns auch viel ist das leider an der wache der tüv abgelaufen war die hatte so eine prüfplakette ja,
und das ist natürlich also das kann man natürlich aus sicherheitsgründen nicht gut finden wenn da die polizistin.
Sag ich mal in einer.
In einer woche ist die nicht technisch überprüft ist ja das haben wir fotografiert und getwittert das ging dann erstmal so also ich glaube dass halt einige reporterin und journalistinnen einen.
Ein google irgendwie hatten of fusion und polizeiwache sodass das oder vier schon viele wache so dass das dann erstmal durch die medien ging dass die polizei da eben mit,
ja sag ich mal abgelaufen im gerät angerückt waren aber es wurde dann von seiten der polizei bestätigt dass die ware nicht ein brust gefährdet ist und,
dass bei einem türchen nur vergessen wurde die plakette drauf zu kleben also wenn ihr das nächste mal wenn ihr demnächst mal ärger habt wegen abgelaufenen türöffner das passiert ja gerne mal dass man vergisst die.
Ja näher wachmeister ist alles okay ich habe schon nur keine plakette.
Genau wir haben das vergessen aber machen sie sich keine sorgen dann hatten wir.
Haben wir einen pressetermin durchgeführt am donnerstag des festivals also das festival.
Das ist glaube ich das ist der offizielle festival zeitraum ist glaube ich donnerstag bis sonntag ne das geht ja immer wieder veranstaltung ist ne hat wochen vorher schon zu tun mit aufbau und sonstigen und auch danach muss das ja abgebaut werden was viele vergessen.
So dass wir an dem tag eins.
Einen presse tag veranstaltet haben da einfach auch um dem medieninteresse dass er nun an der veranstaltung und der lösung oder dem,
dem ende dieses konfliktes bestand eben auch gerecht zu werden das haben wir nach cd konzept gemacht also mit der
mit begleiterin innen die
erstens sind den journalistinnen geholfen haben sich auf dem gelände zurechtzufinden dinge zu finden ansprechpartnerin zu finden dieses gelände ist halt sehr groß ja meine
bestätigung der anmeldung zu dem presse tag beinhaltete so
denken sie bitte ein festes schuhwerk suchen sie eine kamera bedenken sie dass sie viele kilometer laufen müssen bedenken sie das bei der wahl ihres equipment sonnencreme nicht vergessen und eine nachweisbare flasche wasser.
Meine empfehlung und da hinzukommen ja weil es eben weitläufig und eben auch um.
Wie das eben bei den c events auch machen das darauf zu achten dass die menschen die nicht gefilmt werden wollen.
Nicht gefilmt werden ja und das eben sicherzustellen dass wir da keine keine.
Haben mit unglücklichen menschen.
Ähm dann haben wir da ein team gehabt vor ort unterschiedliche unterschiedliche hintergründe von.
Ja direkt vom veranstalter also wirklich mitglieder des kultur kosmos die gesagt haben jo ich habe an dem tag,
um pressevertreter übung zu machen das finde ich gut ich möchte das hier mal zeigen über leute die halt lange in den supporter strukturen sind die also von verschiedenen crews da.
Zum festival beitragen über leute die auch aus dem c kontext kommen die quasi diese tätigkeit der presse enge kennen und dann haben wir also ein schönes team gehabt und haben empfangen
eine
einen bunten strauß an an teams die war da schweriner volks zeitung nordkorea ostsee zeitung welt vierundzwanzig,
zdf ndr zeit online weiß und das kollektiv ich weiß nicht ob die kollektiv dabei kollektiv heißen aber die.
Machen so reportagen auf youtube für im auftrag des öffentlichen rechtlichen rundfunks also so ein funk.
Ein funk teil also funk ist ja dieses.
Diese youtube öffentlich-rechtliche ausgründung für youtube beiträge und die sind ein teil von funk.
Und das war alles insgesamt sehr angenehm also die journalistinnen waren jetzt nicht alle damit,
vertraut dass sie eben eine begleitung bekommen die ihnen viele dinge erklärt einerseits aber andererseits auch,
eben bei jeder kamera einstellung sagt nee das können wir so nicht machen da werden die menschen gegen ihren willen gefilmt oder eben auch einfach mal hingeht und sagt immer wir filmen hier könnt ihr mal.
Könnt ihr eine viertel stunde woanders euch hinsetzen oder wie wie werden wir uns ja eigentlich das waren sie am anfang so ein bisschen misstrauisch aber sind dann auch alle am ende happy gewesen dass sie so viel.
Erklärt bekommen haben in den stunden das ist also eigentlich insgesamt sehr angenehm verlaufen kann man sich viel anschauen es gibt natürlich.
Kurze beiträge die dann so vom ndr oder ipa verbreitet wurden es gibt viel zu lesen in den genannten zeitung.
Und in den tv sendungen und so weiter aber besonders online sind natürlich herauszuheben.
Dass die video reportage von zeit online und die video reportage des,
kollektivs die beide finde ich also die haben jetzt so sich wie lange dauern die ich glaube so zwischen fünfzehn und zwanzig minuten oder fünfundzwanzig minuten werde so glaube ich ist ungefähr die dauer die beide halt ein bisschen längeren,
'n längeren weg daraus gemacht haben längeren weg über das über das festival und ein bisschen mehr,
als die kurz beiträge die eben für die tv sendungen durchgedrungen maßen immer im im ein bis zwei maximal drei minuten bereich sind die kann man sich anschauen nehmen wir mal die show notes,
und die geben da glaube ich ein ein ganz interessanten blick auf das festival geschehen.
Nachdem dieser presse takt dann vorbei war lief eben dass das festival weiter.
Kam dann.
Leider zu einem sehr unschönen und sehr traurigen ereignis am sonntag da wurde ein mensch tot in ein zelt gefunden.
Das war natürlich ein sehr sehr schwerer sehr schwere erfahrung sehr schwere belastung natürlich auch für den,
kultur kosmos der damit umgehen musste wurden die freunde dieser person natürlich ausfindig gemacht und.
Erstmal psycho sozial betreut durch die fachleute des kultur- cosmos die da vor ort sind es wurde dann das festival am,
sonntag also wenige stunden nach dem fund für fünfzehn gedenkminuten unterbrochen.
Das war schon 'n krasser moment also so auf dem.
Am nachmittag war das.
Genau also der im prinzip kann ich sagen so schnell wie es irgendwie möglich war.
Haben wir diese entscheidung umgesetzt das ist das so du kannst so ein festival eben nicht,
mal eben spontan anhalten ne das sind fünfundzwanzig bühnen insgesamt über die das koordiniert werden musste ne da hast du eben eine zeit die du brauchst um das allen zu sagen es gibt zeitpunkte die.
Günstig sind und zeitpunkte die ungünstig sind wenn jetzt irgendwo gerade eine akrobatik show läuft dann kannst du eben nicht sagen unterbrecht bitte die akrobatik show zu dem zeitpunkt für eine viertelstunde.
Und solche dinge dass das so so ich würde sagen die die schnellste reaktion die irgendwie möglich war.
Ist dann in dem fall eben wenige stunden.
Es war auch echt das war der moment hat das wurde uns von sehr vielen leuten zurück gespielt der moment hat seine wirkung nicht verfehlt.
Ja das war also es ist natürlich ein krasses so krasses ding wenn auf einmal dieses dieses festival,
aufhört und du hörst die vögel wieder zwitschern ne das ding gibt ja da gibt's ja keine ruhe da gibt's keine ruhigen moment und es wurde eben auch von den menschen aufgenommen der die bitte des kultur kosmos war eben gemeinsam inne zu halten und zu trauern.
Und das hat hat stattgefunden und war natürlich.
Ja weil war ein rührend oder ein sehr emotionaler moment der eben auch denke ich hier,
zum ausdruck gebracht hat dass das dass das eben eine sehr belastende situation war die und ist die im niemanden niemandem da egal ist.
Das hat natürlich das fazit des festivals jetzt ein bisschen getrübt.
Dennoch muss man ja am ende werden solche veranstaltungen ja in zahlen ausgedrückt da hat die polizei dann am ende berichtet dass sie also.
An ihrer mobilen wache insgesamt sieben anzeigen entgegengenommen hat.
Dabei handelt es sich um vier eigentumsdelikte eine körperverletzung.
Und zwei anzeigen wegen verstoßes gegen das betäubungsmittel gesetzt also jetzt muss man diese zahlen natürlich immer interpretieren erstmal bei anzeigen zahlen werden tatsächlich die anzeigen gezählt nicht die fälle.
Und.
In also zum beispiel die körperverletzung gehörte zu den zu einem der vier eigentumsdelikte solche sachen kommen da nicht immer wird wenn da nicht gesondert getrennt und die,
anzeigen wegen verstoß gegen das betäubungsmittel gesetzt sind nach meiner kenntnis beide.
Weil da halt etwas abgeliefert wurde in die obhut der polizei das heißt die anzeigen müssten im zweifelsfall gegen unbekannt sein.
Mir nicht ganz klar warum leute,
da zur polizei gegangen sind und irgendwelche substanzen abgeliefert haben ich bin mal gespannt ob die polizei die überhaupt noch prüfen wird weil ich könnte mir auch vorstellen dass da mal irgendjemand sagt komm lass den.
Die haben so wenig zu tun lass den mann gramm mehl schenken dann können die sich damit beschäftigen oder so ne weiß ich nicht.
Die straßen verkehrskontrollen die am ende des fusion festival stattfinden sind seit jahren auf dem
also ist ein phänomen dass er seit jahren stattfindet
und die fälle gehen da auch massiv zurück jedes jahr werden weniger fälle bekannt jetzt auch da die geben dann natürlich die gesamtzahl an und sagen dreihundertachtzig straff und ordnungswidrigkeit anzeigen
aber anzeigen sind nicht die anzahl der fälle denn sie sagen es gibt zweihundert strafanzeigen wegen des verdachts des verstoßes gegen das betäubungsmittel gesetzt.
Und etwa einhundertfünfzig anzeigen nach paragraph vierundzwanzig.
Tvg führen eines kraftfahrzeug es unter berauschen mitteln wenn du zu diesen einhundertfünfzig personen gehörst die unter die einen kraft zeug unterbrochen mitteln geführt haben.
Dann kriegst du auch automatisch die anzeige wegen verdacht des verstoßes gegen das betäubungsmittel gesetz.
Sodass du eigentlich um die zweihundert fälle hast.
Einhundertfünfzig die restlichen fünfzig sind dann entweder unbekannt oder beifahrer oder sonst was ja das heißt effektiv und einhundertfünfzig fahrzeuge daraus gezogen die,
unter berauschen mitteln dass der fahrer unter dem einfluss oder die fahrerin und im einsatz brant schnell mittelstand.
Was immer noch viel zu viel ist hundertfünfzig solche autos willst du nicht auf der straße haben aber ein rückgang um ich glaube irgendwas zwischen einem viertel und einem gegenüber dem vorjahr.
Was halt.
Sehr gut ist und bei siebzigtausend menschen die fusion besucht haben sind eben hundertfünfzig.
Die danach ein k f z geführt haben eine.
Eines eine sehr geringer anteil also relativ gering absolut natürlich immer noch zu hoch deswegen bietet die fusion ja seit langer zeit den baseline an also dass die anreise,
mit bussen und oder der bahn und da sind dieses jahr fünfundzwanzigtausend besucherinnen und besucher mit bussen hingefahren.
Also direkt von ihrem heimatort aus und fünfzehntausend wurden dann nochmal geschaltet vom,
bahnhof neustrelitz sodass du am ende bei einer sehr hohen anzahl besucherinnen und besucher bis die nicht mit dem.
Mit dem eigenen pkw anreisen was nicht nur wegen potenzieller gefährdung des straßenverkehrs auf der rückfahrt sondern natürlich auch aus klima bewegungen eine.
Eine ganz gute zahl ist.
Fusion ist zu dem zeitpunkt der größe busbahnhof in europa.
Also da fährt alle alle alle wenige minuten halten voller bus nach nach berlin hamburg und sonstige und vor allem auch der am besten angebundenen kann sein dass es irgendwo noch größere gibt aber keiner ist so
multi angebunden in in viele verschiedene städte das ist wirklich eine irre,
logistischen leistungen die da auch dahinter steckt.
Also mit anderen worten friede freude eierkuchen so wie wir das eigentlich immer haben wollen.
Ja es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen als ich mal also wenn man jetzt den teil anschaut über den gestritten wurde.
Dann ist das die lösung die sich.
Der fusion festival gewünscht hat die von seines filmfestivals auch als ja zukunftsfähig betrachtet wird.
Muss ich natürlich jetzt schon mal fragen wenn du da also diese mobile wache die haben die sich aus niedersachsen glaube ich ausgeliehen die kräfte die da vor ort waren mussten ja auch irgendwie bezahlt werden die sind nachher abgereist,
weil es ja dann da die zu diesem großen waldbrand gekommen ist in mecklenburg-vorpommern das heißt sie haben ihren einsatz frühzeitig beendet und sich um den.
Um den kampf gegen den waldbrand gekümmert.
Die müssen sich natürlich schon dann mal die werden sicherlich evaluieren was sie da beim nächsten jahr investieren müssen um diese zu erwartenden geringen anzahl an anzeigen,
entgegenzunehmen also der wenn du jetzt sieben anzeigen hast dann reicht vielleicht auch das nächste mal ein container statt zwei oder so aber das sind natürlich sachen die muss die.
Die muss die polizei evaluieren.
Wir haben dann noch im auf dem festival gibt's auch einen content übrigens in ziemlich geiler name für das content mit dem content ein wortspiel finde ich.
Gibt es gibt auch erst seit das war jetzt glaube ich das vierte mal.
Ich werde jetzt auch vier jahre geschätzt.
Also war ja noch ein jahr pause dazwischen so aber ähm ja so in der größenordnung ist ein neues konzept wurde glaube ich seinerzeit.
Aus portugal von anderen festival übernommen aber ist auch ein interessanter trend das eben,
es eben hier bei leibe nicht nur darum geht ja jetzt aber draußen die musik läuft und das war's sondern sehr schön dass das fusion festival quasi für den namen ja immer auch extrem passende auch wenn es vielleicht am anfang,
mehr so kulturen und.
Musik meinte das aber hier noch sehr viel mehr funktioniert wird sondern im prinzip die doch relativ offene gesellschaft die sich dort einfindet dann eben auch mit inhalten gespielt werden wenn man sich,
dem sozusagen aussetzen möchte davon partizipieren partizipieren möchte gibt's eben quasi wie es da so viele andere videos gibt die meisten eben mit musik
manche mit theater et cetera gibt es eben auch diese inhalte erreichung im content und ich vermute mal da dürftet ihr über diesen ganzen.
Zusammenhang vorfall rund um fusion bleibt und das hashtag berichtet haben.
Genau äh gibt's eine aufzeichnung von dem vortrag von sari ta eule und mir aus media c d e.
Der den wir auch in den shownotes verlinkt haben.
Gut dann können wir uns ja mal der netz politik widmen beziehungsweise.
Du willst also gar nicht mehr würdigen dass hier
ausgerechnet ein kulturfestival zeigt heute gewinnt die größte schlacht hier tim da muss man noch mal irgendwie noch ein bisschen partners reinbringen der markus heute hat das so schön in seinem artikel gemacht und du sagst einfach nur gut.
Hast du ja schon erwähnt den artikel was soll ich denn da jetzt noch groß zu sagen außer hast du ja jetzt auch noch genug pathos mit reingebracht jetzt reicht's dann aber auch langsam weil mit pathos.
Wenden wir uns wieder dem untergang zu.
Ja der untergang na ja ich weiß nicht ob das nächste thema dafür steht sicherlich nicht dem untergang aber dem wandel den wir uns ja alle ausgesetzt sehen worum geht's es geht um
libera ein vorstoß von facebook um ein neues zahlung system eins.
Ich habe mich da mal ein bisschen rein gelesen ich muss gleich vorweg sagen ich habe mich nicht durch dieses wort
gekämpft aber einige podcast gehört und artikel gelesen und ja das versucht mal so ein bisschen näher zu bringen um da so ein eindruck
zu bekommen weil es wurde natürlich dann gleich weil facebook war natürlich viel rumgeschrien und dämonische des unterstellt und vorhergesagt und überhaupt und der untergang der welt ist nah.
Vielleicht mal so ein bisschen.
Ist er.
Ist er ja gut ist ja schon lange aber kommt irgendwie nicht so richtig näher
worum geht's also facebook möchte gerne ein zahlung system einführen ein,
da liegen teilweise,
digitales also sich komplett im netz abspielen des zahlung system was so mit dem etablierten banken system direkt erstmal nichts zu tun hat.
Und das ist ja in dem sinne nichts neues also wir haben ja schon verschiedene methoden wie zahlung systeme mit dem internet verheiratet werden das erfolgreichste bisher sicherlich kennt auch jeder ist paypal.
Und in letzter zeit haben auch andere player die über große netzwerke verfügen
hier schon mitgespielt da ist vor allem in china eine ganze menge passiert chat oder ali da echt mega große
player und da läuft einfach extrem viel drüber also insbesondere integration in so chats um einfach das hin und her von nachrichten auch noch um das hin und her
von geld zu ergänzen,
über die kann ich jetzt nicht so viel sagen dann haben wir natürlich noch so andere vorstoß e wie apple pay zum beispiel die etwas anders funktionieren weil sie eigentlich sehr viel mehr an den bisher schon etablierten alternativen zahlung system andocken also an der kreditkarten welt ja im prinzip
auch schon mal so eine abkehr von dem
klassischen banken system war und dieses ganze gepflegt von zahlungs dienstleistern hängt über kurz oder lang halt überall miteinander zusammen und übergeben die sind teilweise fließend und teilweise merkt.
Jetzt haben wir ja vor ungefähr zehn jahren äh dann eben diese neue ära eingeleitet gesehen mit der erfindung von bitcoin und mit bitcoin natürlich das passwort des jahrzehnts überhaupt die blockchain,
und auch wenn bitcoin ne ganze menge welle gemacht hat und sicherlich auch der ein oder andere person ziemlich reich andere wahrscheinlich auch arm.
Hat bitcoin eins vor allem nicht erreicht also es ist halt alles andere als ein universalen zahlung system geworden auch diese ganzen anderen ableger die ganzen anderen kryptowährungen wie sie da alle heißen haben dies
nicht erreichen können auch wenn sie für sich genommen 'ne menge geld und investitions kapital angezogen haben also interior ist zum beispiel dazu erwähnen als einer der populären geschichten der rest.
Ich glaube das wird ausgesprochen.
Wie auch immer das ausgesprochen wird also sprich das jetzt so aus wie es für mich passt irgendwie.
Wie ich dich ausspreche entscheide ich.
Ja okay dann ist es vielleicht ist ja die älter welt naja und was.
Nahezu alle diese systeme gemein haben ist diese vorstellung dass man quasi ein zahlung system aufbaut unter zur hilfe name dieser crypto technologie
blockchain womit die ganze.
Systematik der der des halten von werden und werden und das austauschen von werten,
komplett vom aktuellen banken system entkoppelt ist und das ist in dem sinne keine zentralbanken gibt es gibt keine geld ausgeben institute oder organisationen und auch die ganzen transaktionen,
werden quasi offenem netz vorgehalten und diese blockchain stellt halt sicher dass klar ist wem jetzt welches geld zu welchem zeitpunkt gehört und gehört hat.
Problem mit bitcoin ist natürlich dass diese blockchain das wird ja nun auch am laufenden meter,
immer wieder berichtet einen enormen energieverbrauch nach sich zieht und vor allem auch an ganz,
vielen wichtigen stellen einfach überhaupt nicht skaliert also
dauert einfach extrem lange bis transaktion durchkommen dass es mal kritischer mal weniger kritisch aber insgesamt hat das alles kein besonders hohen durchsatz und was noch ein viel größeres problem ist diese ganze bitcoin welt ist halt so entkoppelt von dem
klassischen geld markt das eben auch der wert von bitcoin sehr spekulativ.
Geworden ist und schon immer war und vermutlich auch
bleiben wird das heißt mit bitcoin zu handeln ist so ein bisschen wie mit gold zu handeln das ist halt so irgendwas anderes was heute mal so ein wert hat und morgen hat es mal so ein wert je nachdem
wie geil die leute gerade darauf sind hier zu investieren aber alles eben immer so ein bisschen mit dieser erfahrung
erwartung wenn ich da jetzt geld rein investiere vielleicht kann ich da in der zukunft mehr wieder für mich rausziehen aber es ist halt niemals dieses wirtschafts basierend
system geworden und sagen kann aber wenn ich
coin habe dann geht's mir gut und wie ich habe ein regelmäßiges einkommen in bitcoin damit kann ich alles bezahlen weil alles kann ich mit bitcoin bezahlen und innerhalb meiner bitcoin welt bleiben die preise auch soweit stabil
dass ich eben auch eine vorstellung davon habe dass das was ich einnehme auch einen gewissen dauerhaften wert hat und vielleicht auch in der zukunft nicht in irgendeiner form absichert das ist nicht der fall.
Und das hat viel mit technik zu tun es hat aber auch viel damit zu tun dass es eben nicht teil,
das banken systems ist was nun mal die basis unserer wirtschaft ist das scheiße finden oder so nicht zukunfts gerecht da steht natürlich jedem frei aber es ist normal.
Nun kommt facebook und sagt na ja also so scheiße ist jetzt äh blockchain nicht aber wir sehen schon die probleme damit,
aber wir sehen auch nicht unbedingt die notwendigkeit sie so zu benutzen wie das eben bei bitcoin und co der fall ist nämlich indem sie quasi,
alles öffentlich vorhält und auch permanent
über diesen arbeit nachweis der quasi das absicherung system ist der blockchain also dieses puff of work dieses permanente ausrechnen von fotografische algorithmen,
das das ist sozusagen ein vorgang der ist zu teuer der skaliert nicht und,
der leidet einfach dadrunter das quasi alle da permanent dran teilnehmen müssen und jede einzelne transaktion das machen muss
aber an sich ist es gar kein schlechtes system weil es hat sich ja gezeigt dass man darüber eben sicherstellen kann dass innerhalb eines geld marktes
transaktionen darüber auch abgesichert werden können und haben sich eben was anderes ausgedacht
das system heißt libra das heißt libra ist quasi der versuch so ein neues jahr meine zahlungseingänge in den markt zu bekommen.
Die tatsächlich auch mit einer blockchain abgesichert ist diese blockchain ist eben nicht quasi für jedermann und für jede transaktion gedacht
sondern stattdessen ist libra mehr so ein freies netzwerk wo man sich entscheiden kann dann ein partner zu werden und wenn man
ist dann gibt man selber selber libra aus und nimmt sie ein aber alle transaktionen die quasi innerhalb meines,
meine eigenen welt stattfinden die halte ich selber vor diese libra blockchain ist nur dazu da dass hin und her von geld mit dem,
dieses netzwerks zu richten die,
währung selber wiederum soll aber auch nicht volatil sein also soll nicht solchen permanenten schwankungen unterliegen und wird deswegen nach hinten durch.
Währung klassischen währung systeme,
abgedeckt das heißt all das geld was in diesen libra system drin ist wird tatsächlich,
über einen ist ring ich gerade einen richtigen begriff den man das ein währungs- korb
abgedeckt das heißt man investiert quasi dieses geld auf der anderen seite in existierende währung und darüber stabilisiert sich eben der wert von libra auch.
Über alle währungen hinweg damit ist es natürlich immer noch gewissen fluktuation ausgesetzt aber die entsprechend halt den fluktuation,
die wir insgesamt im währung system auch haben und von daher erstmal so auf den ersten blick nicht schlechter aufgestellt als andere währung auch
hat aber quasi mehr das verhalten von allen währungen gleichzeitig und eben nicht nur einer einzigen,
was ist jetzt lieber organisatorisch
libra selber ist jetzt erstmal nicht facebook facebook dürfte die technologie im wesentlichen entwickelt haben und die ideen beigesteuert haben aber lieber ist zunächst einmal eine die sogenannte liberia assoziation
die sitzt in genf und facebook ist ein mitglied.
Hat ungefähr zwei prozent der stimmrechte und es gibt
bisher achtundzwanzig weitere gründungsmitglieder hundert sollen's maximal erstmal werden zumindest in den ersten fünf jahren und da sind da so schöne unternehmen dabei wie spotify.
Paypal vodafone ebay visa mastercard drei und lüft und uwe.
Coinbase also ganz ganz interessant also man man hat sozusagen
player die selber so digitale güter verkaufen also spotify zum beispiel
die aber auch so in der revolte so ein bisschen angesiedelt sind handels plätze der und die digitale bezahlung gerne sehen würden wie ebay man hat aber auch die klassischen teilnehmer der bisherigen geld,
also paypal visa und mastercard als vertreter der kreditkarten und abrechnung netzwerke,
vodafone ist insofern sehr interessant weil die ja auch in afrika sehr stark vertreten sind mit diesem system was ja da quasi handy basierte zahlung schon seit vielen jahren vorangetrieben hat und die afrikanische wirtschaft nach vorne gebracht hat.
Und dann eben die neuen content da im
transport mag zu über und lift aber es gibt auch gruppen wie zum beispiel also so eine bitcoin extra lange die also quasi zu sehen wollen libra mit ihrer
klassischen kryptowährungen welle zu verbinden das man da quasi geld hin und her tauschen kann und,
aber auch so kleinere hostels wie zum beispiel kippa die so mikro kredite über internet einsammeln und ein entwicklungsländer rausgibt also
sehr unterschiedliche teilnehmer
dazu noch ein paar venture kapitalisten und all die haben quasi wenn sie dann wirklich ihre zehn millionen dollar einlage da mal machen am anfang dann eben das recht als eigener not in dieser libra blockchain mitzuarbeiten und das,
berechtigt die selber quasi so eine wallet rauszubringen und seine eigene finanzwelt und über diese libera blockchain mit den ganzen anderen,
in diesem netzwerk transaktionen auch abzusichern.
Und warum wollen die das.
Na ja ich meine wenn man sich den markt heute anschaut dann gibt's ja schon diverse next für länder und für bestimmte anwendungen von geld also hast zum beispiel.
Enorme geld flüsse international die über,
solche manni gram und und solche dienstleister wo halt geld was in dem ein land verdient wird in ein anderes land transferiert wird also durch migranten durch,
durch leiharbeiter leute die für ein paar jahre in anderen ländern arbeiten ne in dein saudi-arabien türken in deutschland meine wenn du heute,
so am bahnhof gehst und so weiter dann siehst du immer wieder diese kleinen läden wo ich frag so wer benutzt ihr eigentlich ja hier senden sie geld in die ganze welt dass es sozusagen ein ein riesen markt,
um eben geld wirklich in andere länder zu bringen wenn es facebo
und den anderen player hier gelingt ein alternatives zahlung system aufzubauen was ja global funktioniert und was auch eine
finanzielle stabilität hat durch diesen währungs- korb dann wäre das durchaus vorstellbar dass sie solche märkte übernehmen aber natürlich geht es auch generell darum eben auch jeglichen kauf und jeden transfer
mit sehr niedrigen transaktionskosten im internet durchzuführen und damit eben am banken system vorbei an den traditionellen,
geldwäsche dann vorbei davon träumen sie ja im prinzip alle.
Ja
Wie so gibt's auch.
Ja also wie bei it a gibt's auch noch technisch dieses smart contract.
Das heißt in dieser blockchain kann nicht nur geld vorgehalten werden und transaktionen nachgewiesen werden sondern man kann quasi auch in anführungsstriche verträge dort unterbringen also running code der bestimmte dinge.
Überprüfen kann.
Anders als ida haben sie halt nicht so eine deutliche sprache wie javascript genommen sondern eben sich da auch nochmal eine eigene sprache überlegt die hieß move
das ist quasi so eine virtual maschine und du kannst den code aus der blockchain nehmen und in dieser virtual maschine ausführen um bestimmte bedingungen quasi automatisiert zu überprüfen
wie das was das auslösen wird ist andere frage,
eins muss ich vielleicht noch sagen also libra ist diese währung,
und damit auch der pool an dem diese ganzen mitglieder dieser assoziation geld in libra austauschen können mit dieser blockchain.
Das zahlung system was facebook selber plant rauszubekommen das heißt dann.
Und das ist dann quasi so facebook s implementierung von libra.
Aber innerhalb der facebook-welt das heißt wie die da ihre transaktionen speichern,
das vollkommen unabhängig von von der ganzen blockchain geschichte da wird vielleicht sowas gar nicht zum einsatz kommen und wenn dann halt quasi nur in ihrem eigenen in ihrer eigenen welt.
Sprich wir werden halt in zukunft dann so eine app sehen die kaliber heißt mit der du eben irgendwie dinge bezahlen kannst wo sie sich eben in die kaufen oder verkaufen lassen
und andere organisationen werden dann eben ihre eigene interpretation davon haben paypal wird das in ihre app einbauen etcetera mastercard visa werden das in irgendeiner form ihrem system verbinden ebay wird vielleicht zum zahlung system haben.
Ja und ähm das ist jetzt sozusagen erstmal das was hier äh,
technisch geplant ist die frage ist natürlich was was könnte das jetzt eben,
am ende wirklich sein oder nicht sein und was könnte das eben bewirken besser sollte man vielleicht klarstellen also libra ist halt nicht eine währung klar es hat jetzt hin,
namen und leute werden es sicherlich ähnlich bedienen aber es nicht im eigentlichen sinne.
Eine währung stellt sich auch die frage dieser absicherung über diesen währungs- korb und da kommen auch noch so kurzfristige anleihen dazu.
Die frage wie das ganze auch rechtlich von den regulieren in zukunft behandelt werden wird ja also ob das ganze nicht im prinzip so 'ne art ford ist,
ja sowie anleihen aufm markt etfs oder so etwas der dann unter umständen auch noch steuerrechtlichen fragen nach sich zieht nicht beurteilen aber es durchaus eine offene frage zu diesem zeitpunkt ne
die frage wie mit identität umgegangen werden wird in diesem system also ja sicherlich eine pseudonym bezahlung,
vorgesehen und möglich aber so oder so in dem moment wo es um geld geht musste ich natürlich identifizieren also
bei kaliber ist das schon so geplant dass du dann im richtigen ausweis vorlegen muss um dich dann entsprechend dann,
zu registrieren für diesen dienst.
Ja aber es ist halt auch durchaus ein paar chancen hier drin ne also wenn ich an spenden und crowdfunding denke da sind natürlich niedrige transaktionskosten immer so eine sache.
Ähm dadurch dass hier quasi auch automatisch ein wettbewerb gibt mit den verschiedenen betreibern könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen dass sie transaktionskosten hier auch gleich sich relativ niedrig ein,
tun bis hin zu kostenlos weiß ich nicht ganz genau.
Von mir schon erwähnt dieser world money transfer ist sicherlich so einen bereich und generell halt so mikro transaktion also,
überhaupt kleinste beträge zu sammeln kleine beträge zu spenden ab zu zweigen etcetera sowas geht natürlich mit einer digitalen,
zahl einheit sehr viel besser weil du nicht mehr diese groben verluste hast bei hohen transaktionskosten.
Ja und dann stellt sich natürlich die frage inwiefern sich so eine,
so ein zahlung system dann den regulierung der einzelnen länder unterwerfen muss das ist sicherlich alles offen also wer welche anforderungen gibt es hier kann könnte accounts gesperrt können,
beschlagnahmt werden hat das finanzamt zugriff auf so etwas automatisch ich vermute mal sowas muss eigentlich,
hergestellt werden weil sonst funktioniert es nicht und im im bankensektor heutzutage ist es so dass dieser ganze,
action und prävention und diese ganze diese ganze aufwand den man eben für die regulierung dinge betreiben muss wohl relativ hohe kosten erzeugt sodass auch nochmal 'ne frage ist wie sich das jetzt hier,
niederschlagen nichtsdestotrotz denke ich mal als facebook hier durchaus so auf dem weg da einfach unabhängig zu sein
und einfach mal selber über geld zu herrschen das passt natürlich für sie ganz gut und mit den ganzen
usern die sie haben weltweit und vor allem den ganzen user in so schwellenländern wo quasi,
seepark überweisung und der komfort der damit verbunden ist für uns so vollkommen unbekannt ist ja so wo es nicht einfach ist mal eben geld irgendwo hin zu überweisen um was zu kaufen dass sie dort eben mit so einem system ziemlich erfolge feiern.
Warum ist das facebook machen.
Na ja gut ich meine facebook ist ja nicht äh das einzige unternehmen was versucht so etwas zu machen es gibt ja schon paypal et cetera aber facebook hat natürlich da ein riesen vorteil weil sie einfach ein paar milliarden user haben.
Den sie halt mal eben so zack diese funktionalität unterschieden können das bauen sie dann in ihren messenger ein das bodensee in instagram und in whatsapp ein und dann ist das einfach mal in jedermanns hand,
und wenn du mal so mit zwei drei milliarden potenziellen usern starten kannst dann hast du natürlich auch einen riesigen druck von anbietern
dort daran teilzunehmen weil irgendwie ein zahnarzt system was weltweit.
Äh unter maßgabe derselben währung schwankungen benutzt werden kann.
Und du kannst mal eben sagen überweist mir mal hier einen halben libra und dann ist die dienstleistung dein.
Mach das mal global irgendwie mal eben und das das ist natürlich attraktiv also.
Wenn es nicht sozusagen auf regulatorischen ebene von vornherein schon soweit gezählt wird dass das es so nix mehr taucht dann denk ich mal wird das schon seine verbreitung finden.
Und es muss halt auch nicht unbedingt was schlechtes sein ja ich meine es kann natürlich dann sofort die tausend artikel hoch die jetzt die nächste weltverschwörung wittern und,
ja natürlich will facebook damit geld verdienen natürlich wollen sie damit irgendwie ihren einfluss halten natürlich wollen sie damit ihre,
monetarisieren klar ich meine das macht jedes unternehmen und das vertrauen dass man facebook an der stelle entgegenbringen sollte sollte da nicht sehr viel höher sein als man's sonst hat und da müssen wir erstmal
wie es mit ihrem image so weitergeht,
aber äh wir wissen auch dass viele leute daran einfach dran teilnehmen werden und wenn man sich so den erfolg von spenden system wie patrioten et cetera anschaut,
würde mich das nicht wundern wenn in zukunft auch viel der digital bezahlung und auch eben der spenden wege darüber laufen können zumal es eben dann,
weil es eben abgesichert ist über diese ganzen währungsfonds auch eine finanzielle stabilität hat und das ist nun mal das was man von geld eilig sich erhofft.
Ich bin da ja sehr skeptisch.
Ich glaube nicht dass dass wir jeden scheiß in die hände von facebook geben müssen und insbesondere ein währungs- system.
Ist einer der zentralen staatlichen macht und wirkungsvoll.
Und damit natürlich auch einer der zentralen macht und wirkungsvoll faktoren die demokratische staaten haben und.
Bargeld so anachronistisch dass vielleicht gesehen wird hat eine besondere vorteile in den.
Schutzes rechten der bürgerinnen und bürger gegenüber dem staat und,
ich meine da wird diskutiert zum beispiel größere bargeld zahlungen irgendwie zu ihm legalisieren um geldwäsche geld schmugel und kriminell,
also traditionell bargeld gebundenen gewerben dass ein bisschen zu erschweren.
Aber grundsätzlich halte ich das schon für sinnvoll dass wir nicht unbedingt zahlung systeme.
In unseren alltag einfließen lassen die
von irgendwelchen unternehmen bereitgestellt werden und da nehme ich paypal mastercard visa und was weiß ich wenn es sonst noch geben kann gibt genauso mit ins boot wie facebook
nur dass ich bei facebook nun umso weniger den eindruck habe dass die damit irgendetwas geiles schaffen wollen.
Also da bin ich wirklich bin ich wirklich skeptisch auf wenn keine ahnung das cool ist mit mit seiner apple watch zu bezahlen oder.
Natürlich online zahlungen einfach mit bargeld nicht sinnvoll funktionieren da gibt's natürlich,
märkte oder teile aber da gefällt mir der ansatz sogar der ansatz besser das mit irgendeiner blockchain abzudecken auf.
Ja teilweise recht wenig reflektiert sehe oder als für relativ wenig reflektiert halte.
Der was irgendwie ihre ihren einfluss in ihre folgeabschätzung angeht aber jetzt sozusagen geil die facebook währung kommt das ungefähr als ich meine nachdem die ja jetzt schon die öffentlichkeit sind mehr oder weniger,
und das private sind mehr oder weniger jetzt auch noch dass das währung system werden zu wollen.
Ist natürlich aus deren sicht eine naheliegende schritt der sich anbietet.
Ja der wo sollen sie auch sonst noch hin wachsen wo sollen sie unsere gesellschaften und starten auch sonst noch durchdringen aber irgendwie.
Bock hab ich da nicht drauf.
Ist alles gültig nachvollziehbar was du sagst ist allerdings auch ein sehr euro zentralistisch des bild ja also bargeld und so weiter hat vielleicht auch wirklich nur noch in deutschland diese bedeutung.
Nee das stimmt das stimmt tatsächlich nicht ich habe
übrigens das muss ich jetzt erzählen weil mich das selber auch überrascht hat ich war mal auf der konferenz der geld drucker da habe ich mir gedacht.
Bilder berg oder was.
Es gibt quasi es es gibt die konferenz der geld drucker ich wollte mal irgendwie mit den quatschen war da nicht ob ich da nicht in besseren deal kriegen könnte nein es gibt natürlich ein ein relativ breite industrie,
der ich sag mal ungefähr der der security printen also eine branche die.
Sich darauf konzentriert mit mit hohen kunst fertigen äh fertigungsprozesse,
dinge zu schaffen die zu kopieren schwer ist hologramme
irgendwelche komischen filter machen die wenn du so das licht gegen heads grün leuchten wenn es nicht gegen hältst dunkel sind
irgendwelche feinste pigmentierung mit glitzer die auf unsere geldscheine kommen also diese gesamte diese gesamte sage ich mal handwerkskunst.
Der die natürlich auch pässe pass fälschung quasi dadurch erschweren wollen dass sie besonders komplexe fertigungsprozesse dort machen die.
Oder papiere ne weil was weiß ich kannst du wenn du ein pass nachmachen willst kriegst du allein schon das papier nicht.
Auf dem der gedruckt ist und so weiter und so fort ja da habe ich einen vortrag gehalten über wie.
Die fälschung sicherheit digital funktioniert um in meiner so dieses,
nein der einstieg in den vortrag war so ein bisschen so ich finde das super witzig wie kommt eigentlich auf die idee dass man das nicht dass man diese sachen nicht einfach nach produzieren kann.
Und dann so ja weil das nicht geht dann war der punkt ja aber ihr könnt sie doch auch produzieren warum sollte nicht jemand anders das genauso können also was was ist jetzt wenn ihr es doch könnt wie kommt ihr überhaupt auf die idee zu sagen das können andere
oder das das würde wäre wäre anderen unmöglich
interessanterweise zwei sachen von diesem von dieser konferenz ich mitgenommen haben erstens diese industrie bargeld also der der verbrauch und die anwendung von bargeld nimmt weltweit,
zu beziehungsweise stagniert nicht was mich auch stark gewundert hat.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen dass ab jetzt spekulation dass der effekt daher kommt dass in den noch nicht besonders reichen ländern.
Quasi du noch sehr viele bargeld basierte menschen hast der englische fachbegriff dafür ist ja an beengt also eine person die kein konto.
Bei einer bank unterhält,
ja weil sie vielleicht auch keinen festen wohnsitz hat oder weil sie ohnehin kein geld übrig hat was sie einer bank anvertrauen könnte hast du natürlich in asiatischen in indien hast du weißt,
da sind natürlich irgendwie zwei ständige prozent zahlen der menschen anbelangt das heißt ihren leben handelt.
Bedrückt sich in bargeld aus jedenfalls fazit war der der der markt für bargeld ist im moment noch im wachstum.
Ja gut aber die leute die an bank sind sind halt teilweise schon bei facebook und werden dann über facebook dann halt bei facebook ne das ist äh dann eben genau dieser trend der sich dann abzeichnen könnte weil natürlich ist.
Da da würde ich mitgehen aber bargeld ist im moment der einzige punkt was wollte ich erzählen weil mir das auch so überrascht hat dass dass das bargeld noch nicht wirklich auf dem rückzug ist erstaunlicherweise.
Ja aber ja aber ich rede jetzt konkret von schwellenländern sozusagen von ländern in denen einfach die wirtschaftliche entwicklung
schon immer extrem nachgegangen hat und wo sich langsam was tut und man hat das halt in afrika gesehen was die einführung eines digitalisierten zahlung systems in form von
pisa gebracht hat dass sich da auf einmal sehr schnell eine wirtschaft entwickelt hat die vorher so einfach nicht
bargeld nicht möglich gewesen wäre schlecht weil den leuten einfach das geld geklaut wird oder sie keine möglichkeit haben es mal eben über größere strecken hinzu sicher zu überweisen so war das einfach mit dem handy mit ein paar äh,
ich weiß gar nicht genau wie man das bedient aber im wesentlichen ist glaube ich so also eine art sms artige kommunikativ
damit war sozusagen das alles möglich heutzutage wenn du das dann eben über so eine kaliber a oder wie auch immer die app dann eben heißt durchführen kannst ist schon mal 'ne andere sache
es gibt natürlich solche systeme schon paypal et cetera pp nur da hältst du dann eben dein geld eben in einer.
Original währung vor und muss dann darin eben sozusagen mit anderen handeln
wenn sie denn überhaupt dieselbe währung teilen oder teilen wollen bei die bra ist es so dass du quasi währungs- übergreifend arbeiten kannst war's halt nur noch libra als einheit kannst du im prinzip weltweit eine transaktion machen und hast eben ein über alle,
existierenden währungen gemittelt werden ich sag nicht dass.
Gleicher hat der us-dollar die ja auch immer gesagt.
Ich sag auch nicht dass es jetzt toll und ich sag auch nicht schön dass das endlich gibt ich sag nur wie es ist ja also es hat einfach so funktioniert es,
das ist der p deswegen kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen dass es seine verbreitung finden wird,
ja ich denke es hat auch seine grenzen es hat definitiv wird sich jetzt noch abwarten lassen wie wie die regulierung aussieht welchem druck diese regulierung,
sowohl von nationalen als auch über nationalen strukturen welchem druck das sozusagen mit diesem system macht,
wer überhaupt noch daran teilnehmen will weil außer facebook,
ist jetzt da kein wirklicher digital riese mit dabei ich denke da kann man ebay mal rausnehmen ja die frage ist halt eher was macht google was macht apple was macht.
Microsoft was machen die unternehmen die jetzt sozusagen hier auch nicht auf den kopf gefallen sind in der lage sind sich große systeme zuzulegen und komplexe digital strukturen aufrechtzuerhalten spielen ja mitmachen die was eigenes übernehmen sie diese idee wenn wir dann sozusagen mit vielen solchen
währung oder zahlung system ausgestattet sein so oder so,
zahlung systeme und das hin und her von geld ist das große ding im netz jetzt es hat sich lange abgezeichnet.
Jetzt kommen wir eben an diesem punkt wo wir eben es mit schon großen existierenden user netzwerken zu tun haben,
facebook natürlich das größte aber balla bin ich das einzige und diese user netzwerke werden versuchen solche zahlen systeme zu machen facebookseite ansatz ist jetzt hier ganz interessant ist technisch interessant weil er eben sozusagen von,
den lehrern der kryptowährung das herausnimmt was sozusagen für sie funktioniert einem diese probleme mit der skalierung et cetera
so in diesem system nicht drin ist wenn genug andere probleme bleiben und wird einfach abzuwarten sein wie das ist aber ich will das jetzt gar nicht bewerten ich will einfach nur sagen
so stellte sich derzeit da wird spannend zu sein dass sich entwickeln zu sehen und dann können wir da auch immer noch ordentlich drauf rum
ich persönlich bin jetzt seht zwar die vorteile von bargeld sehe aber auch die nachteile und denke mal wir werden ohnehin in eine zunehmende digitalisierung dieser ganzen transaktion abgleiten,
deshalb.
Ich fühl mich jetzt ja fast dazu dazu gezwungen zu sagen lieber lebe ich anbelangt als dass ich irgendwie meine zahlungen über facebook abwickeln und wenn sie auch nur zwei prozent da drin sind.
Aber ich sage ja auch da bist du nicht in der mehrheit bist du auch nicht der trend.
Das war ich selten tim.
Was du bist nicht der trend naja.
Der trend schon aber nicht.
Naja.
Der trend geht übrigens auch zum fünf g noch nicht mehr.
Ich möchte ich möchte an dieser stelle noch zwei also wir haben ein paar artikel.
Zwei werbeblock.
Zwei artikel haben wir ja
mehrere artikel haben wir für verlinkt konkret wollte ich aber an der stelle weil mir das interessante einblicke geliefert hat mal die diskussion um libra beim
bei unseren kollegen von den mikro ökonomen dem metronom podcast
daraufhin wer verweisen mikro ökonomen ausgabe nummer,
einhundertfünfundvierzig mit dem schönen titel wird facebook mit lieber die welt beherrschen da ist es sehr schön diskutiert worden und dann gab's noch einen längeren artikel von marcel weiß auf neun jetzt dot com auch verlinkt ist der
auch sehr viele aspekte da zusammen gefickt hat.
Marcel weiß ja hab ich gesehen den artikel lange nichts mehr von gehört äh aber der neuen netzwerk com immer mal wieder sehr interessante beiträge.
Genau und jetzt können wir mal gucken wie es mit der telekommunikation so vorangeht ich bin ja nee ab nächster woche bin ich ja dann wieder in deutschland dann werde ich ja wieder betroffen.
Nicht mehr.
Liebe so kurze erreichen dann ist es für dich echt krass also wir hatten uns ja letzte woche noch kurz gesehen auf einer privaten veranstaltung und kaum saß ich da irgendwie im zug dann gab's wieder dieses gel und dieses
auf meinem telefon manchmal auch drei geh das war ja schon gute zeiten aber
das ist einfach immer noch frappierend dass wenn man sich in europa ein bisschen durch deutschland bewegt das einfach sofort die internetversorgung weg ist aber das verdammt viel viel viel viel viel besser werden weil wir haben jetzt ganz viel geld eingenommen.
Ja wir haben jetzt erstmal die telekommunikationsunternehmen die diese fünf g netz zu bauen sollen schau mal um sechs einhalb milliarden erleichtert ja.
Eins eins drin ist eins komma eins milliarden telefonjoker eins komma vier milliarden wurde von eins komma neun milliarden deutsche telekom zwei komma zwei milliarden für teile des spektrums.
Ich hoffe dass wir dazu nochmal eine eigene sendung machen können deswegen behandeln wir das jetzt eher kurz.
Aber das wird jetzt kein die einnahmen sollen ja kein p s werden ne keine unerwarteten mehreinnahmen zur tilgung von staatsschulden sondern das war ja dann tatsächlich investiert werden in den netzausbau.
Genau da gibt's jetzt also.
Ich möchte einmal noch ganz kurz die seite der provider hier kurz würdigen ich hoffe dass es in einer anderen sendung nochmal länger schaffen.
Ein teil des möglichen fünf g spektrums stand und zwar ein signifikante teil ich glaube ungefähr ein drittel stand überhaupt nicht zur.
Zur option sondern wird für die industrie vorbehalten die sich eigene fünf plätze damit bauen soll das ist natürlich insofern problematisch als das,
sicher zeigen sollte dass oder zumindest sehr viel darüber geredet wird dass dieser fünf g steine in den in nächster zeit.
Nicht unbedingt das and consumer ding sein wird.
Noch nicht und wenn du jetzt natürlich von seiten der benefits a sagst okay hier diese ganzen industriellen anwendungen die ja sehr viel wo man sich ja sehr viel potenzial für fünf g
verspricht stichwort edge computing und warte nicht alles für scherze darf das natürlich auch nochmal ein dicker.
Ein dicker teil der rewe finanzierungsmöglichkeiten die die provider irgendwie sehen können mit ihren fünf g setzen
ja kann man gut oder schlecht finden was ich auf jeden fall bedauerlich finde ist das relativ klar ist diese sechs komma fünf milliarden euro
die muss ja irgendjemand bezahlen und im zweifelsfall wir wenn wir in der bahn sitzen und kein netz haben dann zahlen wir nämlich genau diese sechseinhalb milliarden euro den irgendwoher werden diese unternehmen die ihre netze ja mit gewinn.
Absicht errichten die werden die wieder haben wollen diese investiert.
Jetzt gibt's also einen einen streit um diese hohen erlöse vodafone sagt na ja der aktions erlös solle an die bieten bieten in unternehmen zurückgegeben werden.
Also nicht in den breitbandausbau in die digitale ausstattung von schulen wie es ja der plan ist sondern in den mobilfunkausbau.
Über förderprogramme also sagen quasi okay im moment ist der deal gut wir nehmen die sechseinhalb milliarden wir bauen damit brand breitband aus und und unsere schulen,
und jetzt sagt wo da vorne dann gibt das geld mal auch uns dies bezahlt haben um so um unseren ausbau zu fördern ja das ist,
auch ein argument was man.
Was man jetzt von vodafone seite vertreten könnte ne dass man quasi sagt okay natürlich wollen wir dass die das hier diese die das recht ein mobilfunknetz zu bauen an die ambitionierten vertreterin der zukunft
vergeben wird dann aber eher quasi als verpflichtung dieses geld auch auszugeben und damit das geld auch wirklich ausgegeben wird
kommt kommt das erstmal zu uns und dann gehen wir das in förderprogramm zurück ja also da da streitet dann vodafone telefonie c a.
Hat die bedingungen die die bundesnetzagentur für die frequenz vergabe noch vergeben hat als irrsinn sie würden nämlich dadurch im ausbau ihrer mobilfunknetze gebremst und,
klagen gegen diese bedingungen deutsche telekom.
Auch unzufrieden haben aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe ein funknetz ein fünf g funknetz irgendwo schon in betrieb genommen weitgehend,
ohne dass der privat drin wären die nicht irgendwelche test geräte von ihnen betreiben ich bin da ein bisschen.
Gespalten inzwischen wenn ich mir überlege die so diese sechseinhalb milliarden euro wenn die dann den unternehmen auch wirklich fehlen um fünf g netze zu bauen dann ist das vielleicht nicht unbedingt für uns förderlich andererseits sagen natürlich,
für die die kehrseite des argument s wäre naja weil sie jetzt erstmal so viel geld ausgegeben haben müssen sich jetzt wirklich reinhauen damit diese investitionen in die,
spektren sich überhaupt wieder refinanzieren und bauen umso geilere netze ja das mag sein trotzdem werden diese netze erstmal für uns alle sechseinhalb milliarden euro teurer,
als sie es unter anderem bedingungen gewesen wären da würde ich gerne nochmal eine ein eine wachsende jung zu machen deswegen,
machen wir das an dieser.
Na ja ich meine es mündet ja hier auch in unserer,
das können wir vielleicht einfach mal mit rein nehmen also das ist für mich hier so ein bisschen teil der geschichte die frage ist ja immer.
Was überlassen wir einfach komplett in unternehmen und was an digitaler infrastruktur,
verstehen wir dann sozusagen auch als gemein gut und fahren wir nicht besser damit
wenn wir infrastrukturen die ohnehin alle anbieter brauchen wo aber der besitzer einen einzelnen auch für alle etwas schwierig sein kann
warum übernimmt das nicht der staat und vermietet diese infrastrukturen an diese unternehmen die das dann brauchen weiter erscheint ja einen neuen schritt gegeben zu haben es wurde eine bundeseinheitliche masten gesellschaft gegründet.
Die mit genau ich muss sagen davon hatte ich überhaupt nichts vorher gehört und das finde ich
jetzt auf den ersten blick erstmal für eine gute idee oder gibt's hier irgendetwas was man daran zu was man daran kritisieren sollte aus deiner perspektive.
Also was sie was sie lösen wollen es sie wollen sagen effektiver ausbau der mobilfunknetze wir haben viele weiße flecken.
Und wir werden jetzt in grundstücken und liegenschaft in der öffentlichen hand masten errichten.
Und die technik an diese masken können dann die mobilfunk betreiber ihre technik dran knoten,
masten sind im besitz des bundes und diese mick wird dafür sorgen dass die das masken dort errichtet werden wo wo funklöcher sind damit die,
die betreiber dort ihre antenne dran knoten können.
Ja das ist doch ein
ein gutes beispiel für eine sinnvolle investition ja also hier werden ja wohl priorität grundstücke liegenschaft in der öffentlichen hand herangezogen werden da braucht man dann so ein mast auf und wer auch immer gerade jetzt sozusagen mobilfunkausbau
baut kann sich dort einmieten und muss durch diesen sucht prozess oder das sich anmieten von infrastruktur bei einem
konkurrenten kann sich dann sozusagen ersparen es wird zu denselben bedingungen für alle hier.
Es ist glaub ich 'ne 'ne sinnvolle idee es ist aber nicht so als hättest du jetzt in der freien wildbahn nicht auch massen auf den mehrere mobilfunkanbieter sich dran geknetet haben ne.
Es ist,
also der teil den ich tatsächlich nicht weiß ist wie sich die kosten für den betrieb eines zelt haus zusammensetzen ich weiß dass strom signifikante teil ist also die haben einen eigenen zähler,
er sagt nicht komm mach mal mit ne das.
Ist aber einfach zu lösen das problem.
Ja genau aber es geht nicht um das problem sondern es geht um die frage wie setzen sich die kosten für den betrieb eines zelt haus zusammen die hardware muss gekauft werden,
die kosten auf jeden fall sechsstellig die,
miete muss monatlich bezahlt werden da weiß ich tatsächlich nicht wieder so die preise sind und der strom muss bezahlt werden das ist irgendwie
natürlich musst du dann noch die kapazitäten im im im back bauen und so weiter schaffen im im koran und so weiter das ding auch irgendwie anbinden und so weiter muss jemand hinfahren das ding muss versorgt werden da gibt's natürlich
ganz viele telekom männchen die mit dem auto rumfahren und dann irgendwie da mal mit dem schraubenschlüssel gegen hauen und wenn der wenn der gerade spinnt dass das das sind alles kosten und ich weiß tatsächlich nicht.
Wie genau die das torten diagram.
Für einen selten aussieht und wie viel davon jetzt tatsächlich die miete des massen ist der sich an dem gebäude befindet das weiß ich tatsächlich nicht und danach richtet sich ja dann,
auch die frage wie.
Wie sinnvoll unsinnig oder wirklich erleichtern diese möglichkeit nun für die.
Für die netzbetreiber wirklich ist meine vorsichtige schätzung wäre.
Hallo nie miete die location ist wahrscheinlich also ich würde schätzen.
Schwierig aber vielleicht maximal zehn prozent aber es kann sein dass sie.
Da können wir jetzt natürlich rum spekulieren wie wir wollen aber so oder so ist es auch klar dass die motivation eines.
Schreibers eine eine eine andere ist diesen platz überhaupt erstmal zu erschaffen ja da wird sozusagen gesehen wir sind hier unterversorgt um ihr höhere abdeckung mit höheren bandbreite zu haben brauchen wir eine höhere dichte
wir richten diese plätze ein wir haben auch zugriff auf kommunale liegenschaft wir können das mal durchführen
da muss nicht ein einziges unternehmen sozusagen das beschließen damit mal anzufangen und dann müssen die anderen irgendwann
auch mal beschließen sich da in der nähe auch noch was zu suchen oder mit dem anderen zu verhandeln
ob sie da unterkommen können sondern der platz ist einfach mal da und diese ganze schwelle ist schonmal niedrig gesetzt und die kosten sind am ende,
fallen nicht höher als sie wären wenn sie das selber betreiben.
Ja das ist richtig noch einen punkt der natürlich wichtig ist für eine location ist also wenn du das nicht machst wie,
wie e-plus beziehungsweise jetzt telefonjoker und das sag ich mal ich glaube die haben achtzig prozent des netzes über mikrowelle angebunden also über mikrowellen riecht antennen,
dann
also die zahlen sind jetzt immer irgendwo her geschüttelt kann sein dass da varianten ist ja die haben auf jeden fall die mehrzahl ihrer seltener über mikrowellen richtern angebunden.
Wenn du jetzt eine mick machst dann musst du natürlich auch eigentlich dafür sorgen dass da eine schöne glasfaser anliegt ne also wenn du irgendwie und das wiederum ist hier die idee dieser mix das die stadtwerke das hier kooperiert wird eben von,
bundesebene mich mobilfunk infrastruktur gesellschaft auf bundesebene in die kooperation gegangen wird mit den.
Kommunalen unter anderem auch den kommunalen versorgen stadtwerke,
die im ländlichen raum durchaus auch mal die eine oder andere glasfaser in die erde gelegt haben.
Um hier das voranzubringen ich finde das super ich bin mal gespannt wie viel das dann tatsächlich.
Das wirklich attraktiver macht den ländlichen raum zu versorgen denn wir erinnern uns die argumente,
die netzbetreiber haben die dagegen sprechen den ländlichen raum zu versorgen ist ah es ist und wirtschaftlich und b ihre vorgaben sind erfüllt wenn sie so und so viel prozent der haushalte versorgt haben.
Genau nicht der fläche und hier ist jetzt der stellt sich dann eben die frage ist das ist dieser schritt ausreichend.
In der absenkung der kosten und der erleichterung des ländlichen ausbaus wenn.
So dass es auf einmal wirklich nennenswert lukrativer und interessanter wird für die mobilfunknetz betreiben ist 'ne frage muss ich einfach mal 'ne mobilfunknetz betreiber stellen.
Ja aber so vollkommen unabhängig von dem mobilfunknetz betreibern einfach wenn es eine initiative gibt des bundes
oder der gemeinden ja in gänze also der öffentlichen hand überhaupt dafür zu sorgen dass wir eine zunehmende vermischung von standorten mit glasfaser haben.
Dann ist es am ende sogar fast nicht mal entscheidend,
dann die mobilfunkanbieter an dieser stelle dann auch sofort zuschlagen sondern du schaffst ja sozusagen überhaupt erstmal brücken standorte von denen aus auch über die glasfaser angebote gemacht werden kann wenn da ein mast irgendwo in dem ort steht dann
und der wird auch über glasfaser angeschlossen dann öffnest du natürlich auch die tour für eine direkte kabel gebundene,
anschluss möglichkeit an das netz also was auch immer da der output ist ich würde das vor allem nicht da drunter nicht diese maßgabe mit ist das jetzt wirtschaftlich diese masten aufzubauen.
Ja aber das ist das das ist das problem was sie lösen müssen dass es dir dass das kernproblem deswegen machen wir das ja.
Für die für den mobilfunk dran betreiber wirtschaftlich mal so ja das ist klar dass sie denen ein angebot machen muss
aber es ist nicht unbedingt primär wichtig diese standorte wirtschaftlich zu erschließen weil du damit eben,
alle gemeinden und damit die bürger und damit eben auch die unternehmen erschließen und daraus hast du einen einen sekundären nutzen nämlich dass die einfach mal an die moderne infrastruktur angeschlossen werden aber in zeitgemäßer technologie
und da kann man dann eben auch mal in die miesen gehen was soll's solchen ausbau betrifft genauso wie man das ja mit straßen und so weiter auch.
Also ich bin mal sehr gespannt dass also wie viel infrastruktur dann wirklich in diesem mast drin ist ob die sagen wir gehen in baumarkt und holen uns eine lange stange und schrauben die aufs dach oder ob sie sagen ne da liegt auch noch eine glasfaser dran.
Du die können auch einfach frei funk wlan dranhängen dann ist auch schon mal was gewonnen.
Nee das ist echt nicht nein ach du meinst da oben an den mast ich dachte du meinst den ablenkung zu dem masten über frei funk.
Nee nee nee das nicht
die legen da schön glasfaser die hundert dinge die sich über glasfaser anschließen oder selber über mikrowellen man die können sich ja auch von maß zu machst irgendwie verbinden das letztlich nicht egal ist egal ja aber selbst wenn noch kein mobilfunk betreiber da ist das ist ein mast sofort braucht hängt man erstmal wlan ran,
so
Läuft das schon ja einfach das netz das wlan-netz deutschland das wäre doch mal schön einfach so ein wlan was.
Nur von ich sehe.
Dass ich mein optimismus noch nicht verloren habe.
Du meinst wir werden demnächst als als als drei master der drei master deutschland.
Genau wo ist ursula von der leyen wenn man sie braucht.
Publik ja okay also werden wir mal.
Wir müssen hier die digitale gorch fock brauchen wir.
Bitte nicht.
Oh das ist ja so genial dieses dieses gorch fock manchmal wenn wir langweilig ist google ich gorch fock und guck mir an was wir vier milliarden wir gerade für restauration eines eines seelisches aus holz aufgeben.
Na ja es ist ein symbol.
Der letzte mal war glaube ich dass die dass diese diese werft die die von der leyen ja dann äh mit dem auftrag ruiniert hat
zuletzt jetzt diese dieses segel schiff als fand halten wollte um noch irgendwie ausstehende aufträge bezahlt zu bekommen was auch geiles wir sind inzwischen so krass unser militär ist so weit ruiniert ja das privatunternehmen unsere kriegsschiffe als fand halten
um unsere zahlungsverkehr zeit irgendwie zu erpressen.
Na ja jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir eine eigene masken gesellschaft ja vielleicht kriegt ihr auch den drei master wieder hin dann haben wir unsere digitalen drei master und dann läuft es auch wenn ihr gerne hier machst aufstehen ja wir wollen drei.
Als nationales symbol der erreichbar.
Alles symbol der erreichbarkeit,
da kann man dann hilft oder sowieso das wohl der freiheit ist auch nichts dahinter aber kannst du dir mal angucken und sagen ist schön ja wunderbar so machen wir das,
symbole anbindung.
So weiter im text.
Jo spielt nach wie vor eine große rolle wir haben den
fall von heise hier behandelt die von der emoji oder im mai heimgesucht wurden die haben jetzt am ende ein artikel geschrieben dass sie sagen obwohl sie
gut reagiert haben kompetent reagiert haben und die sache ja dann doch mit einem.
Letztendlich mit einem blauen auge überstanden haben haben sie ein schaden davon getragen von weit über fünfzigtausend euro sagen diese fünfzigtausend euro ist ein sind nicht schäden die sie sich jetzt irgendwie,
errechnet haben somit ach ja die betriebs die die personen stunde,
redakteur kostet so und so viel und normalerweise schafft er so und so viel mehrwert und das hat jetzt ein paar tage nicht stattgefunden beziehungsweise nicht redakteur sondern bürokraft was auch immer also nicht irgendwelche ausgedachte schäden sondern wirklich die wo sie auch eine rechnung für haben.
Die also den den ertrag des unternehmens heise verlag oder heise gruppe eben auch im in diesem jahr,
schädigen oder bremsen und das ist natürlich auch trotzdem mal 'ne sehr sehr krass hätte ich liegt aber übrigens auch in den erwartungen ungefähr,
dass solche kosten eben relativ schnell mal anfallen und das ist natürlich für mich weil ich dass das ein.
Fortschrittliche angriffe auf 'm millionen unternehmen wie den heise verlag dann ist das natürlich.
Immer noch eine ziemlich geringe summe.
Dann thema rente denke ich in der letzten woche wurde dann der juwelen händler.
Erwischt das ist eine.
Ja kann man sagen kette wir haben auf jeden fall mehrere geschäfte weltweit die mit mit mit gold und glitzersteinen handeln und.
Da kommst du mal deine rolex oder nicht.
Ja die gehen immer so schnell kaputt diese rolex ne also das ist irgendwie ärgerlich und nein bist du noch da oder putz du gerade deine rolex.
Ja ich bin auch da ich frag mich jetzt weil ich freue mich nur gerade wobei wenn man erwischt wurde.
Ne wenn du wurde nicht erwischt wenn er hat's erwischt nämlich ja
und das ist der deswegen interessant weil das risiko modell wenn du mit mit glitzersteinen und juwelen handelst mit glitzersteinen und gold handelt
ist natürlich dass ihr das jemand wegnehmen möchte weshalb die dann ihre läden mit panzerglas bauen und
und sowas weiter ne und und irgendwie bewaffnete sicherheitskräfte haben und und so weiter ne.
Wurden jetzt gehackt und hatten eine schadsoftware infektion.
Und die haben da offenbar nicht so so so,
gut reagieren können wie bei heise sondern wann wurden etwas kälter erwischt und haben dann eine sehr hohe lösegeld forderung erhalten wo nicht ganz bekannt ist welche das war aber
sie waren auch also sie waren hier betroffen ist zeigt halt sehr interessant dass,
selbst ein geschäft wo du jetzt sagen würdest ne das risiko modell eines juwelen hitlers ist dass ihm wollt und juwelen gestohlen werden und deswegen investierte in physikalische in physische sicherheit,
ist natürlich sehr interessant dass sie dann eben einen fall haben und.
Dann natürlich die erpresser sich auch gesagt haben oh.
Der google war mal kurz bei wem wir hier gelandet sind oh die haben wahrscheinlich geld und haben das dann auch.
Wohl offenbar gefordert warum erzähle ich das na ja das problem bleibt.
Existent betrifft immer mehr unternehmen wir lesen da jeden tag von und da habe ich aber eine kleine anekdote zu ich setze mich ja mit solchen sachen,
beruflich sehr viel auseinander und da haben wir mach das teilweise mal zum spaß.
Einfach mal so aktuelle mal mal anschauen bisschen analysieren was tut die so wie verhält die sich und.
Wie ist sie geschrieben solche sachen wenn man mal ein tag zeit hat und da haben wir uns eine schöne windows v m genommen und haben die installiert haben die infiziert mit der mit dem trojaner crab.
Ist also eine auch sehr erfolgreiche.
Die ich glaube in der ersten variante waren sie nicht so gut da konnte man die könnte man die wiederherstellung irgendwie auslösen aber inzwischen ist das ein recht gut laufendes unternehmen und die.
Haben wenn du wenn du jetzt leute mit seiner mit seiner branche infiziert hast was sie macht es die verschlüsselt alle dateien auf dem computer
mit einem mit asymmetrischer verschlüsselung und verkauft ihr dann den kiel den du brauchst um das zu zu entschlüsseln und die haben.
Und zu diesem zwecke natürlich dann sehr so so webseiten die als tor hin service in der regel betrieben werden diese seite kannst du dann besuchen,
und da hast du dann ein schönes user interface,
wo gesagt wird aha hier also bei erstens du musst innerhalb von ich glaub zehn tagen oder sieben tagen bezahlen sonst erhöht sich die,
die forderung von tausend auf zweitausend us-dollar in unserem fall zweitens gibt.
Wo du eine datei hochladen kannst und du bekommst die entschlüsselt datei zurück.
Einfach nur der der sinn davon ist natürlich dass sie beweisen dass sie in der lage sind deine dateien wiederherzustellen ne die kriegen ja nur geld wenn sie deine wenn du dann auch bezahlst und deswegen
bieten die diesen beweis an dass sie die dateien wieder herstellen können,
also lasst euch da nicht einreden wenn euch irgendwelche leute erzählen niemals geld an erpresser zahlen man weiß nicht,
ob die dateien wirklich wiederherstellen totaler unsinn wenn sie die datei nicht wiederherstellen würden.
Dann ist das ja für ihr geschäftsmodell nicht besonders gut denn das stunde ja relativ schnell in der zeitung und hätte dann eben unglückliche kunden gibt es auch solche fälle absolute,
minderheit der fälle und dann haben die einen kundensupport in dem fall von,
war das konnte man zahlen.
Ich glaube monetär o monetäre oder bitcoin oder ihn so eine andere gibt's nicht.
Ich will gerade irgendwas mit dir sag mal so eine.
Durch coin.
Äh genau ja genau.
Ich glaube das war mit dir.
Fällt mir gerade nichts zu ein.
Ich gucke mal ganz kurz ja also es gab zwei so zwei so währungen die man da wählen konnte und ähm da die die.
Vielleicht was auch monetäre wie auch immer es gab auf jeden fall zwei so kryptowährungen die man da jetzt irgendwie die der wahl ja.
Und dann haben die auch immer so ein support chat ja der war sehr schön denn mit diesen support chat kann man sich ja dann unterhalten.
Und das war sehr sehr nett dann haben wir uns nämlich da hingesetzt und haben in radio brechend in englisch irgendwie so gesagt so ui.
Bei bitcoin.
Natürlich ist dieser support statt musste dann erklären nein das bitcoin kannst du nicht bei uns kaufen das musst du woanders kaufen und dann uns geben ja aber weil das eben die meisten leute nicht können gibt es eben diesen support dann haben wir gesagt
ja das war 's aber das ist ist mir aber ein bisschen zu kompliziert opfer denn nicht per banküberweisung zahlen könnten ja
wer viel einfacher geht auch schneller und so alles irgendwie ein bisschen weniger kompliziert nee geht auch nicht ja und haben dann halt so ein bisschen diesen diesen support auf englisch in schlechten englisch so ein bisschen zeit gekostet.
Bis wir dann gesagt haben denn ich hatte einen kumpel dabei der.
Wo wir bis wir dann einfach in auf russisch geantwortet haben und gesagt haben ey.
Sprecht ihr vielleicht auch russisch weil wir können nicht so gut englisch in muss also wir haben immer ich gesagt ne ich muss immer so getan als eine person und die antwort war na klar selbstverständlich wenn die russe.
Und.
Daraufhin daraufhin haben wir das gespräch dann auf russisch weitergeführt und er fragt wie kommt es dass du russe sprichst ne.
Du bist doch in deutschland also die sammeln natürlich auch informationen über den rechner sehen ne also ab und so du bist doch in deutschland ja geantwortet ja nee ich bin hier nur auf ich bin hier beruflich nur für zwei wochen.
Okay für wen arbeitest du denn antwort was sagen antwortest du natürlich in russland der fragt für wen du arbeitest.
Gerade gehackt hat.
Nein du antwortest natürlich gazprom weil das.
Ja
Gastronom ich arbeite für das in zwei wochen in deutschland
oh wie es denn also wurde dann nochmal freundlicher und schritt mehr man merkt man bekam keine standard antworten ja ob man denn ob wir denn,
ein russischer staatsbürger werden.
Ja gesagt ja klar wo ich wohne in moskau ne ich wohne da und da und arbeite für gastronomie bin jetzt nur für vierzehn tage hier und dann kam die wunderschöne antwort ich hab's auch echt nicht geglaubt dass ich in google trends lädt gepackt habe.
Mache ein foto von deinem pass.
Du kannst die relevanten informationen mit dem finger verdecken alles was ich brauche es ein foto von deinem pass und im hintergrund unseren chat damit ich sehe dass es wirklich dein pass ist.
Und wenn du mir das geschickt hast kriegst du die dateien kostenlos wiederhergestellt.
Denn wir haben einen kostenlosen service der der daten wiederherstellung für bürgerinnen und bürger der russischen föderation.
Oh wow konntet ihr das dann auch noch produzieren.
Ja und dann haben wir dann haben wir irgendwie erstmal ein paar screenshots gemacht und die habe ich jetzt gerade jetzt gerade nicht gefunden dass wir da hätte ich auch sehen können was diese andere währung ist
und ja das wars erzähle ich die geschichte weil damit natürlich klar war dass es sich hier,
auf jeden fall um angreifer handelt die aus russland stammen nicht weil sie russisch sprechen sondern weil sie offenbar,
gegenmaßnahmen treffen bürgerinnen und bürger russlands tatsächlich zu infizieren und das macht,
häufig diese einerseits darüber dass sie als allererstes mal die language settings,
sich anschaut oder versucht herauszufinden ob dieses ob das zielsystem.
Sich in russland befindet über die ip-adresse russische der teilnahme hat oder sonstiges und um so eine russische eine infektion von russischen geräten zu,
vermeiden
deswegen hat er uns auch angesprochen und sagte so ey was machst du in deutschland ja weil er sich gewundert hat das überhaupt ein russe infiziert war zweitens.
Diese diese möglichkeit dann zu sagen okay wenn russin oder russen infiziert sind dann
möglichst denen keinen schaden zuzufügen sondern einfach nur sagen okay gibt kurz den beweis und wir stellen die dateien dateien kostenlos wieder her und das machen die natürlich alles um in russland kein ärger zu bekommen denn.
Die sagen wir mal die cyber politik russland was kriminalität angeht ist,
du möchtest gerne hacking machen gerne du hast das gesamte internet für dich kannst da drin hacken wie du möchtest.
Aber wenn du leute in russland hat dann kriegst du natürlich auch russischen ärger und das bedeutet du kommst in russischen knast.
Und selbst ein russischer hacker will nicht in russischen knast niemand will im russischen knast und diese diese sage ich mal selber außenpolitik russland fahren die seit vielen jahren sehr gut,
und so hatten wir eben hinzu sage ich mal einen sehr.
Ein sehr gutes indiz dass es sich hier tatsächlich um russische um russische angreifer handelt.
Hätte natürlich auch immer wieder es ist bei indizien hätte auch alles gefälscht sein können zur täuschung aber das war schon.
Sehr nahe liegender sehr naheliegend des indiz und gestern vorgestern hat dann brian crabs seine.
Recherche veröffentlicht der auf der suche war nach den leuten hinter der und wir erinnern uns crabs ist
ein nadeln loser investigative journalist im bereich der it-sicherheit zuletzt haben wir glaube ich über ihn gesprochen als er.
Opfer der stärksten detox attacke der geschichte des internets war nämlich das mir net das ja seine webseite da platt gemacht hatte.
Und dann diese service angefeuert so stark dass aka mai dann ihm den.
Die den kostenlose das kostenlose hosting abgesagt hat weil sie nicht mehr in der lage waren diesen,
angriff entgegenzutreten und dann google irgendwie sagte ach komm wir haben hier noch ein horst dann legen wir das da drauf dann können wir wieder deinen blog lesen und der dann auch dem das keine ruhe gelassen hat und der daraufhin dann den,
nach mehreren monaten recherche veröffentlicht hat wer im zweifelsfall der autor des netzes ist das hat jetzt auch nochmal mit gerne gemacht und scheint jetzt auch fündig geworden zu sein und hat,
drei russische personen ausgemacht denen er jetzt mit allerlei winzigen.
Fehlern über jahre auf die spuren gekommen ist auch ein ganz auch ganz interessant zu lesen wo.
Eigentlich die leute auch wieder beispiel
was wir in unserem vortrag über opfer rechter besprochen haben ne wieder verwendung von crestencia über jahre sich identitäten aufbauen und dann einmal einen fehler gemacht und sind
dadurch eben dann an so jemanden wie brian crabs.
Gescheitert und stehen jetzt im internet haben aber natürlich auf auf e-mail anfrage geantwortet hey ich habe eine sehr schöne eine sehr schöne.
Sehr glaubhaft.
Sehr sehr glaubhaft.
Diese kryptowährungen mit d wenn sie wirklich mit diva könnte es vielleicht desch gewesen sein.
Das genau der.
Das war mir.
Bin die ganze zeit durcheinander gekommen mit mit dezember das ist der ddr da oder der usa und dezent dieses irgendwie so neuer fernseher streame.
Ja ja.
Ja den hab ich über der ddr und der es habe ich irgendwie durcheinander gebracht.
Ne also bei diesen gibt's gibt's gibt's fußball und bei dusch gibt's geld.
Seine dateien zurück.
Man weiß auch gleich warum das bei diesen leuten dann zum einsatz kommt mal kurz die wikipedia liest hier ist eine openhouse kryptowährung die vergleichbare funktionalität wie
coin aber auch darüber hinaus gehende bietet ein besonderes augenmerk wird auf datenschutz gelegt so sind bei der im gegensatz zu anderen kryptowährungen transaktionen informationen nicht öffentlich dies wird durch das system privat cent formales cent ermöglicht dabei
werden transaktionen mit denen anderer personen vermischt und damit verschleiert ein anderer name für dich war auch da coin.
Und es in venezuela die beliebteste kryptowährung das sagt.
Ja gut die das nur noch kurz über den ganzen ein bisschen zu achso ich habe noch einen vortrag gehalten vor ein paar wochen an der ruhr universität bochum.
Wo ich eingeladen war das hat mich sehr gefreut da gibt's auch einen kleinen bericht drüber da ich ein bisschen über die menschlichen schwachstellen gesprochen weil bei all diesen angriffen spielt immer,
der menschliche faktor eine rolle und eine sehr große nämlich den der erst infektion oder den ersten schritt ins,
gelände wo dann eben bei.
Nicht lange gewackelt wird und bei emoji doch noch einige zeit recherchiert wird um sicher zu stellen dass auch die backups verschlüsselt sind und der afd.
In händen der angreifer ist wie wir es bei heise gesehen haben damit werden wir aber jetzt dann glaube ich wirklich bei den kurz meldungen,
e-mail ist kein telekommunikation dienst das war eine frage mit der sich der europäische gerichtshof lange auseinandersetzen musste denn,
die es gab hier offenbar die bestrebungen
der dass das das diese das mail als telekommunikation dienst eben auch den pflichten unterliegen würde die nach telekommunikation gesetz abhören und so weiter.
Gelten und das es interessanterweise von der bundesnetzagentur damals angeregt worden die eben web dienste
die mail oder whatsapp mit telekommunikation diensten gleichsetzen möchte.
Kann man ja verstehen an einer gewissen größe und gewissen regulierung grad werden eben industrien auch grantig wenn es konkurrenz gibt die.
Die für die andere regeln gelten und das war der auslöser,
dieser auseinandersetzung und bedeutet eben auch dass jetzt die das das also die anforderungen für abhören mechanismen nicht in der form,
für für e-mail gelten wie sie für,
schwede kommunikations dienste gehen das heißt aber natürlich nicht dass eure daten bei google oder bei bei e-mail vor dem zugriff durch dritte oder strafverfolgen.
Geschützt wären es ist eben nur die rechtliche grundlage dafür und in welchem kontext das geschehen muss.
Schau mal okay das ist die gute nachricht der woche aber ist halt wie gesagt so ich mein für diejenigen die e-mail nutzen ne.
Dann haben wir einen interessanten artikel
gefunden der vor kurzem veröffentlicht wurde über vr anbieter vor pendeln weiter spielen ja hier auch immer wieder eine rolle thorsten und ich haben da in unserem vortrag du kannst alles hättest du darfst dich nicht erwischen lassen drüber gesprochen frank.
Hat als er letzte mal hier in der sendung zu gast war auch darüber gesprochen dass.
Rein von der von den betriebskosten her ein v n.
Um die und in richtung von zehn us-dollar kosten muss um sag ich mal kommerziell betrieben
werden zu können kommerziell im sinne von es gibt irgendwie 'ne hotline und
support und so weiter und das ist ja doch einige anbieter gibt die überraschend niedriger ihre dienstleistung anbieten bei vollem service und da gab's jetzt einen sehr schönen artikel auf,
wo mal aus den firmen hinter vielen v n anbietern hinterher spionieren wurde gibt's also siebenundneunzig vw
die hier untersucht wurden und die gehören am ende nur dreiundzwanzig unternehmen viele davon chinesisch ja
sich also das ist so ein bisschen so aussieht als wären die vw die den chinesen angeboten werden von den chinesen.
Betrieben um sich so quasi die überwachungskameras täten über jene zurückzuholen die versuchen.
Ihnen zu entkommen.
Das ist ja geil das heißt sie sind dann auch alle in china verfügbar.
Äh teilweise da gibt's wiederum eine andere website apple fenster ship dot com glaube ich heißt die wo du sehen kannst welche welche apps verfügbar sind und welche nicht,
ist auf jeden fall mal ganz spannend und beleuchtet eine frage die viel zu selten gestellt wird nämlich kann ich dem,
vw anbieter der vertrauen weil wir
tatsächlich allen traffic darüber senden und das ist dann natürlich eine frage die man sich genau stellt wenn man sich zum beispiel entscheidet so ein v n,
zu benutzen sei es für das gesamte haus für die gesamte wohnung für den gesamten rechner oder für den gesamten,
internet fuhrpark eine frage die nicht uninteressant ist und hier wurde da mal ein bisschen mehr.
Aufmerksamkeit darauf gelenk deswegen wollte ich das quasi im nachtclub an die sendung mit frank hier nochmal erwähnt haben.
Es gab einen langen streit um das glyphosat gutachten.
Welches überfragt den staat angefragt und dann.
Öffentlich wurde und dann über das urheberrecht versucht wurde das wieder von frag den staat herunter zu kriegen.
Der begriff den eine selbst dafür auch sehr prägt ist das zensur heber recht ja also über das urheberrecht die freiheit,
die informationsfreiheit hierzu grenzen einzugrenzen und zu zensieren.
Da hat jetzt ein gab es zunächst eine,
einstweilige verfügung gegen frag den staat sodass das glyphosat gutachten runternehmen mussten aber das landgericht köln hat dann diese eine einstweilige verfügung wieder aufgehoben somit dürfen sie,
dass die veröffentlichung wieder online stellen und inzwischen hat barbara streisand.
Dass glyphosat gutachten schon dreimal gelesen und die haben sich jetzt auf jeden fall.
Wie mal wieder einen großartigen gefallen damit getan ist auch sehr schön das hier mal gegen diese,
unsinnigen versuche die informationsfreiheit einzuschränken vorgegangen und erfolgreich vorgegangen wurde.
Sehr schön gut gemacht.
Außerdem haben wir berichtet über den werbeblock streit ja wo eine existenz bei google wo es um eine um eine existenten geht die bestimmte content filter nutzen.
Und google hat jetzt zu der breiten,
und diese soll ja abgeschaltet und durch eine andere ersetzt werden google hat jetzt auf zumindest auf die breite und laute kritik der plugin anbieter reagiert mit der äußerung so sinn sinngemäß
niemand hat die absicht werbeblock abzuschaffen es soll tatsächlich um die
veränderung dieser erweiterung entwickler gehen und damit soll es die möglichkeit geben sicherere und performance,
werbeblock zu schaffen das ja sehr schön ne wenn der browser hersteller der sagt das was du machst das können wir dir wir verbieten die das jetzt so zu machen wie du das machst damit du es sicherer und performance da macht die werbeblock anbieter sind noch nicht ganz so überzeugt aber.
Google sagt also sie werden jetzt für diese neue längere block listen
längere block listen zulassen das war einer der kern kritikpunkte dass die neue sehr viel kürzere block listen nur zulässt und außerdem
geschwächt werden es müssen aber jetzt natürlich noch ein bisschen konkretere zahlen folgen eine,
konkrete zahl benennt aber auch google beziehungsweise die premium entwickler die sagen naja.
Diese ursprüngliche die die kompletten zugriff auf sämtliche web inhalte gibt ja also alles was.
Ihr aufruft kann diese kann das ding sehen das sieht also die nicht nur.
Teile der webseite sondern die gesamten inhalte und sagen die comedy entwickler wenn wir bösartige browser plugin finden.
Dann benutzen zweiundvierzig prozent der bösartigen browser erweiterung genau diese.
Das ist einer der gründe warum wir die weghaben wollen.
Ich denke das ist ein wichtiges argument was auch eine rolle spielt auch hier sehr unter beleuchtet und relativ häufig von,
thorsten schröder aber benannt das problem der browser erweiterungen die sehr sehr weit,
reichende rechte in euren browser bekommen die sehr viel zukunftsmöglichkeiten haben und irgendwie nur wenig audi zitiert werden.
Und es gab da glaube ich auch vor einigen jahren mal deinen vortrag von thorsten wo auch mal gezeigt hat wie einfach es ist eine bösartige browser erweiterung,
zu platzieren und wir erinnern uns auch an die recherchen von forma wahrscheinlich jetzt zwei drei jahren war das.
Von eckhart und jasmin klopft da die diese browser erweiterungen gezeigt haben.
Die nach und nach aufgekauft wurden und dann eben zu werbeträger umgebaut wurden auch das eine sehr sehr unschöne zustände also generell die empfehlung.
Die anzahl der browser erweiterung sollte sich,
auf das notwendige minimum reduzieren und die browser erweiterung sollten hoffentlich aus.
Guten qualitätskriterien stammen und nicht irgendwie ach ja um dieses video von youtube runterzuladen brauche ich noch den so zu.
So und so erweiterung mit dem sohn so player sonst was app die ich noch irgendwo installieren muss das geht gerne auch mal schief.
Also dieser streit geht weiter und immerhin dieses argument dass diese ip von.
Na immerhin mehr als ein drittel fast die hälfte der bösartigen erweiterung genutzt wird ist natürlich auch ein punkt dem könnte man natürlich aber auch dadurch begegnen dass.
An ein besseres vermischen modell baut für seine für seine.
Webbrowser erweiterungen ähnlich wie wir das ja erste ansätze auch gut sehen in den,
mobil mobilgeräten wo dann drin steht okay diese erweiterung möchte auf folgendes zugreifen achtung damit könnte sie das und das tun möchtest du das wirklich.
Ja ich weiß nicht ob es damit allein getan ist meine diskussion hatten wir letztes mal schon so ne ob man sozusagen diesen zugriff überhaupt gewähren sollte an sich weil wir da mal da ist dann wird er halt auch irgendwie missbraucht werden und das ist halt genau das problem an der.
Ja ich bin da gespalten also sicherheit ist einerseits eine schöne sache und
andererseits sind werbeblock eine schöne sache leider hat man bei den werbeblock ein ähnliches problem wie bei den vfb du weißt nicht was die mit den daten machen die sie da kriegen und da gibt's auch das eine oder andere sehr schwarze scharf
die welt ist.
Führen auf jeden fall dazu dass ich jetzt weniger lese im netz.
Ja die aber das sind ja die die app locker blockaden.
Ja ja die michael sozusagen jetzt ausschließen weil ich da nicht mehr lesen darf finde ich nicht irgendwie mich registriere und sonst was und das hat damit fallen halt einfach viele zeits einfach bei mir komplett raus weil ich will.
Ja man kann genau dass ich jetzt auch nicht sein lassen wenn ich zeit habe was selten der fall ist dann gucke ich mal in die konsole und schreibt mir nochmal so ein user skript was diese
blogger blogger wieder außer kraft setzt aber das ist auch wirklich ähm da muss ich den artikel schon wirklich lesen wollen.
Genau.
Näher für die also für den für den fall dass ich dass ich wirklich mal ein artikel lesen muss und keine meiner maßnahmen der umgehung von adblocker bloggern unmittelbar funktioniert dann hab ich halt noch ein zweites browser ne
kennst du der trend geht zum zweiten browser.
Leider muss ich ähm.
Leider muss ich dann jetzt in zunehmenden maße auch irgendwie netzwerk um konstituierung von dem offenen scheiße zu werden zu können anderes thema andere leute problemfelder kommen wir zu.
Den terminen.
Und die termine sind mal wieder etwas.
Längerfristig angekündigt wie es sich gehört am dreizehnten september feiert netz politik seinen fünfzehnten geburtstag mal wieder mit einer das ist netz politik konferenz,
in der volksbühne zu berlin es gibt einen käufer papers wo ihr vorträge einreichen könnt ihr könnt auch tickets kaufen ich hoffe auch das zu schaffen dort zu sein.
Und dann freuen wir uns auf eine schöne ein tägige konferenz mit party von netz politik.
Und wer nicht genug bekommen kann von dieser themen lage der ist dann eine woche später auch herzlich eingeladen in dresden dabei zu sein denn dort finden die daten
buchen zweitausendneunzehn statt unter dem schönen motto patch gehabt genau am einundzwanzigsten und zweiundzwanzigsten september im zentralwerkstatt in dresden
wer noch ein vortrag oder workshop oder andere aktionen einreichen will kann das tun wir haben den link auf den ver
links und kann auch eine mail schreiben bis zum fünfundzwanzigsten achten kann man sich da noch bewerben.
Das wasser auch schon.
An die termine für september heute schon präsentiert im juli.
Ja das was musst du den kalender die daten schon die daten schwulen gehören in den kalender das ist.
Da wenn ihr das einrichten könnt besucht die daten spuren das ist vor allem spannend weil jetzt in dieser neuen location zentralwerkstatt sind ich weiß nicht ob sie letztes jahr auch schon da waren war letztes jahr nämlich leider nicht bei den daten.
Ich weiß auch nicht ob auch schon die location davor habe ich schon verpasst.
Davor waren sie in diesem museum für für menschen technik museum.
Irgendwas technik tralala wir wissen richtig bescheid hier.
Genau da gab's oben so 'ne so 'ne da gab es umso eine technik erfahren.
Technische sammlungen heißt das in den technischen sammlungen in dresden genau das wars.
Genau das war die technischen sammlungen jetzt in dem zentralbank das ist der neue space wo auch der c zwei glaube ich irgendwo an gegliedert ist jetzt habe ich mir immer noch nicht angeschaut ist aber interessant und.
Da da da entstehen.
Schöne neue strukturen in dresden und gerade da will man sie ja auch haben.
Ja womit wir am ende der sendung angekommen sind.
Genau damit sind wir am ende der sendung und äh die dankes liste ist weil wir ja fast ein monat war ich nicht im netz politik tim assad hier hast du gar nicht gar nicht vermisst ne fast ein monat.
Habe ich die vermisst.
So dann.
Der einzige.
Deswegen gibt es eine etwas längere dankes liste jetzt mal wieder.
Und zwar danke ich für einmalige und vor allem auch für fortwährend unterstützung dem christian dem thomas,
drei thomas und um ehrlich zu sein dem dirk dem andreas michael fabian jens ralf.
Benedikt ahne tim matthias björn daniel tore peter.
Michael tobias benjamin christian markus alexander clemens steffen steffen alexander kai martin matthias simon tim.
Und daniel ja das war's.
Achso wenn ein habe ich vergessen sorry das tut mir leid herzlichen dank auch an er sieht das war's.
Ja es fällt mir nicht ein also wird ein bisschen schwierig werden mit unserer regelmäßigkeit im sommer,
aber wir versuchen immer mal wieder sendungen einzustreichen so es sich denn,
ergibt wir haben jetzt keine durchgehende voll deklarierten sommerpause aber wir werden alle ein wenig unterwegs sein und das macht dann etwas schwer.
Du sollte euch aber nicht davon abhalten weiterhin hier auf den kanal zu hören und auf neue sendungen zu warten oder.
Nein
also das ist ja auch tatsächlich so dass das sommerloch bei logbuch netz politik nicht nur dadurch kommt dass wir den sommer verschiedenen verreisen sondern auch daher dass in dem
politischen sommerloch
sich auch etwas seltener dick oder in etwas weniger stärkt walter stärke liegt die themen ansammeln insofern machen wir hier die sendung im sommer immer etwas weniger.
Du willst aus aber wir haben euch nicht vergessen wir sagen tschüss bis bald.